Hey everybody! with Dawa Maan. Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So pretty excited. We have an awesome guest to talk to us about a really interesting topic that is really on the vanguard of things. It's data ops, which a lot of folks might have not heard of, but we're going to cover that topic in depth right here today. And I'm so excited that I have Dawa Maan on the show to, you know, he's really an expert in this field to go through it with us. Thanks so much for coming on the show, Dawa. Thanks for having me. Excited to help your audience learn about this cool new merge of data and DevOps. Cool. Great. Really excited to have you here.
大家好！我是 Dawa Maan。交给你了，杰森。大家好。我很兴奋。我们请到了一位非常棒的嘉宾，来跟我们聊一个非常有趣、而且确实走在时代前沿的话题。这就是数据运维（DataOps），很多人可能没听说过，但我们今天就要在这里深入探讨这个话题。我很高兴能请到 Dawa Maan 来到我们的节目，你知道的，他真的是这个领域的专家，能带我们一起了解。非常感谢你能来参加节目，Dawa。谢谢邀请。很高兴能帮助你的听众了解数据（Data）和开发运维（DevOps）这个很酷的新融合。酷。太棒了。很高兴你能来到这里。
Before we get started, why don't we jump into your background as an engineer and technologist. How did you get into the field? And how did you get your first job? And how did you get to where you're at right now? All right. Yeah, we can go back quite a way. So when I was growing up, there were always computers around the house. My father had been the first person in his family to have a computer. And this wasn't just a Windows machine, Internet Explorer. It was always Linux of some kind. So I grew up with Mandrake and Red Hat and SUSE Linux.
在我们开始之前，为什么不先聊聊你作为工程师和技术人员的背景呢？你是怎么进入这个领域的？你是怎么找到第一份工作的？又是如何走到今天的呢？好的。是的，我们可以追溯到很久以前。当我长大的时候，家里总是放着电脑。我父亲是他家里第一个拥有电脑的人。这不仅仅是一台运行 Windows、装着 Internet Explorer 的机器，它总是某种 Linux。所以我是在 Mandrake、Red Hat 和 SUSE Linux 的伴随下长大的。
And there's a whole list of distributions that were tried out. And very quickly, I learned that computers were not just this device that you use for email or work processing, but it's something malleable. It's something to debug at times, you know, Linux being Linux. And it was something that I saw as this whole world that potentially opened up for me as an avenue for creativity. Yeah. Were you worried about bricking your computer? Because I mean, that was one thing that I was worried about when I was in high school, that I would somehow irrevocably damage this machine. Did you have that fear or were you kind of inoculated from that? I think that because we had different Linuxes, so all these different times anyway, the fear of just
还有一整串尝试过的发行版。很快，我就了解到，电脑不仅仅是你用来发邮件或文字处理的设备，它是可塑的。有时候它还需要调试，你知道的，Linux 就是 Linux。我把它看作是一个向我敞开的全新世界，可以作为通往创造力的途径。是的。你担心过把电脑弄成“砖头”吗？因为我的意思是，那是我上高中时担心的事情之一，我担心自己会以某种方式对这台机器造成无法挽回的损坏。你有过那种恐惧，还是说你对那种情况已经有免疫力了？我想，因为我们用过不同的 Linux，总之都是这些不同的系统，所以弄坏操作系统的恐惧并不是那么高，因为我们无论如何都已经习惯每隔几周或几个月就重新安装一次东西。因此，只要存有数据的硬盘没问题，我们就没事。实际上，把电脑搞成砖头依然很难，或者至少在那个时候是这样。我猜在如今稍微更加封闭、受控的环境中，那种可能性会更大一点，但也无所谓了。
messing up the operating system wasn't that high because we were used to reinstalling stuff every couple of weeks or months anyway. So as long as the hard drive with the data was fine, we would be fine. And actually bricking a computer is still pretty hard, or at least it was back then. I guess in today's slightly more closed, controlled environment there, that possibility is larger, but also less anyway.
（接上条）
Anyway, I know that was never a fear, but I learned really quickly that there was something where I could unleash my creativity. So when I was nine years old, a friend realized that when you go into Microsoft Word and you hit the save as HTML button, it would then open in your web browser rather than the Microsoft Word application. And this unlocked a whole world for us because this web browser, which had previously been the domain of big brands and professionals and adults, was suddenly something that we, being little nine-year-old kids, could manipulate and
不管怎样，我知道这从来不是一种恐惧，但我很快就了解到，有些东西可以让我释放创造力。所以当我九岁的时候，一个朋友发现，当你进入 Microsoft Word 并点击“另存为 HTML”按钮时，它会在你的网页浏览器中打开，而不是在 Microsoft Word 应用程序中打开。这为我们打开了一个全新的世界，因为这个网页浏览器以前是大品牌、专业人士和成年人的专属领域，突然间变成了我们这些九岁的小屁孩也能操纵的工具，
get our own stuff to show up. So this went from local HTML files, and then we realized that there's such a thing as a web host. And of course, to us, it was crazy to ask my father for permission to spend like five bucks a year or something for a domain name, but he relented. And we were able to actually have a website that we could share with our friends, so they could sort of see our musings.
并能展示我们自己的东西。所以这从本地 HTML 文件开始，然后我们意识到还有网络主机这回事。当然，对我们来说，要求我父亲批准每年花个五块钱左右买个域名简直是疯狂，但他最终还是心软了。我们真的拥有了一个可以与朋友分享的网站，这样他们就能看到我们的胡思乱想了。
And pretty quickly, this went from html and css to learning php through some tutorial that was available online and pretty much every day after high school or primary school initially when we would come home and our friends would go and play video games we would go and program and learn new technologies and build little nifty tools to scratch our own itch and this led to pretty quickly at age 11 so just at the beginning of high school finding this online community where people in the netherlands which is where i grew up were posting kind of projects that they wanted to solicit basically bids on they wanted to find developers to implement whatever their company needed or some small php script is this like a
很快，这就从 HTML 和 CSS 发展到通过网上的一些教程学习 PHP。基本上在高中或小学放学后的每一天，一开始当我们回家时，我们的朋友们都去玩电子游戏了，而我们则去编程、学习新技术，并构建一些精巧的工具来满足我们自己的需求。这很快在 11 岁时——也就是刚上高中时——引导我们找到了一个在线社区，在荷兰（也就是我长大的地方）的人们会在那里发布他们想要征集投标的项目，他们想寻找开发者来实现他们公司需要的任何东西，或者一些小型 PHP 脚本。这就像一个
like a physical bulletin board or is there a website with job listings like how did this actually materialize so it was a website web forum called site deals where there was one of the sub forums was about like i need this to be done and then people could just respond with i'll do it for this amount at this time and us being 11 year olds we could basically undercut everything working with with our prices. So we ended up working for, you know, the equivalent of about $5 an hour all the way through high school. How did you masquerade as adults?
物理公告板，还是有一个带有招聘信息的网站？这到底是怎么实现的？所以它是一个名为 Site Deals 的网络论坛，其中一个子论坛是关于“我需要完成这个”，然后人们只需回复“我将在什么时间以这个价格完成它”。由于我们当时 11 岁，我们基本上可以用我们的价格压倒一切。所以我们在整个高中期间都在以相当于每小时 5 美元左右的报酬工作。你是怎么伪装成成年人的？
Like, how did that work? I mean, there's no way they were actually fooled because we didn't have any kind of tax ID. It was just, you know, money being wired straight into our bank account. We were 11-year-olds, and I'm sure that our writing reflected that to a degree.
那是怎么做到的？我的意思是，他们不可能真的被骗到，因为我们没有任何纳税人识别号。这只是，你知道的，钱直接电汇到我们的银行账户里。我们只有 11 岁，而且我确信我们的文字在某种程度上反映了这一点。
But we still had to learn how to do contract negotiation and and requirements and and you know due dates delivery deliverables multiple stages of of delivery and payment and everything else so we learned pretty quickly how to be pretty convincing not so much at being adults as at being professionals who could actually build stuff that worked and that was the only requirement people had for us at the time. So all through high school, it was a lot of that freelance web development. And then at some point when the iPhone came out and the iPad came out, I was really intrigued by that platform. And I taught myself Objective-C as well and Cocoa Touch. I saw something really interesting about Objective-C. I don't know if
但我们仍然不得不学习如何进行合同谈判、需求、截止日期、交付成果、多阶段的交付和付款以及其他所有事情。所以我们很快就学会了如何表现得相当有说服力——与其说是在装成成年人，不如说是在装成能够真正构建出可用东西的专业人士。这正是当时人们对我们的唯一要求。所以在整个高中期间，都有大量的这种自由职业网页开发。然后当 iPhone 和 iPad 问世时，我对那个平台真的很感兴趣。我也自学了 Objective-C 和 Cocoa Touch。我在 Objective-C 身上看到了非常有趣的东西。我不知道这会不会
this will blow your mind, like it blew my mind, but you know how in iOS there's NS everything, like NS object, NS socket. Next step, right? Yeah, that's right. It's from next step. So short tangent here, but Steve Jobs left Apple, was kind of kicked out of Apple, started a company called Next and built this machine. Was the machine called the Next Step? I mean, it's starting to hit the limits of what I know here. But anyway, so they started calling everything NS because of Next Step, because of the Next machines. And then when Apple acquired Next
让你大开眼界，就像它大开眼界一样，但你知道在 iOS 中一切都是 NS 开头的吗，比如 NS object、NS socket。Next Step，对吧？是的，没错。它是来自 Next Step。这里扯远一点，史蒂夫·乔布斯离开苹果，被某种程度上踢出了苹果，创办了一家名为 Next 的公司并制造了这台机器。那台机器叫 Next Step 吗？我的意思是，这开始触及我所知范围的极限了。但无论如何，因为 Next Step，因为 Next 机器，他们开始把所有东西都叫作 NS。然后当苹果收购了 Next
and Steve Jobs got back in, that has stuck around to this day. So that blew my mind. I've seen NS object everywhere, but I never knew why there's NS on everything. Yeah, it's really interesting. Like some of the, you know, of course, Apple during those years, Steve Jobs was away. Well, we're not doing as well as they are today, for example.
而史蒂夫·乔布斯重掌大权时，这个命名习惯一直保留到了今天。这让我大开眼界。我到处都见过 NS object，但我从不知道为什么每样东西上都有 NS。是的，这真的很有趣。就像其中的一些，当然，苹果在那几年里，史蒂夫·乔布斯不在。嗯，他们当时的发展不如今天那么好，举个例子。
And the technology that really was at the foundation of everything from the modern Mac OS to the iPhone and everything, definitely it came from Steve Jobs' other company, Next Step. Super, super interesting. But yeah, I taught myself that. I taught myself all the NS prefixes and this really wacky, you know, square bracket syntax that Objective-C came with. But this led to me building, you know, an iPhone app for my high school that pretty
而作为现代 Mac OS 到 iPhone 以及一切事物的基础的技术，绝对来自于史蒂夫·乔布斯的另一家公司 Next Step。超级超级有趣。但是的，我自学了这些。我自学了所有的 NS 前缀，以及 Objective-C 自带的这种非常古怪的方括号语法。但这促使我为我的高中开发了一个 iPhone 应用程序，几乎
much every student and teacher ended up having installed on their phones, which allowed them to really quickly check the schedule, where they had to go for the next class, but especially also the changes in schedule when, you know, the room was changed, or when some kind of class fell through, because the teacher was out sick. And I didn't, I never did freelance iPhone development. But being sort of active in this Twitter, iPhone development, teenager space, led me to getting into contact with some people in the Netherlands who were setting up a Mac and iPhone development studio where they were going to be building productivity applications basically for the Mac and the iPhone on the App Store. And I ended up joining them and then really quickly becoming the lead developer at age 16,
每个学生和老师最后都在他们的手机上安装了这个应用，它允许他们非常快速地查看课程表、下一节课要去哪里，尤其是当教室更换时，或者当老师生病缺席导致某节课取消时，课程表的变动情况。我没有，我从来没有做过自由职业的 iPhone 开发。但在 Twitter 上的 iPhone 开发青少年圈子里比较活跃，让我得以接触到荷兰的一些人，他们当时正在建立一个 Mac 和 iPhone 开发工作室，打算在 App Store 上为 Mac 和 iPhone 构建生产力应用程序。我最终加入了他们，并在 16 岁时迅速成为了首席开发人员，
that must have been. So for a few years there, I was after school, every Monday after school, I would go into the office and then work with them there until like 3 a.m um and then try during the week try to fit in a few more hours of work and that was really exciting a few of our applications got uh got got featured on the app store but after a few years we realized that it was actually pretty hard to make a lot of money on the app store in the beginning when your application is new you can drive a lot of traffic you might get featured blogs might cover you but then after that it's hard to keep that up especially if your first version is already pretty much exactly what you had in mind
那一定是个好时候。所以在那里呆的几年里，我放学后，每个星期一放学后，我都会去办公室，然后和他们一起工作到凌晨 3 点左右，然后试图在周内设法多挤出几个小时的工作时间。这真的令人兴奋。我们的几个应用程序在 App Store 上受到了推荐，但几年后我们意识到，要在 App Store 上赚到大钱其实相当困难。在刚开始时，当你的应用程序是崭新的，你可以带动很大的流量，你可能会获得推荐，博客可能会报道你，但在此之后，很难维持这种状态，尤其是如果你的第一版已经非常符合你的心意，
and there's a ton of surface area for improvements or additional features so they decided to wind that company down and then one of my bosses at the time he had decided uh he was exploring this new startup with a previous business partner of theirs and they decided that they wanted me to join as co-founder and cto so at age 18 we co i co-founded a company with them called stingo where we built a web-based platform for bed and breakfast owners to manage their entire online presence so that includes their website their guest communication their reservation calendar and basically providing a whole tool set for what an old school bed and breakfast, not just a room in Airbnb, but one of these mom and pop shops that really care about their house style, and they make you breakfast
而且还有大量的改进或附加功能空间时。所以他们决定关闭这家公司。当时我的一个老板决定，他和他们以前的一个商业伙伴正在探索这个新的初创公司，他们决定让我作为联合创始人兼 CTO 加入。所以在 18 岁时，我和他们共同创立了一家名为 Stingo 的公司，我们为 B&B（住宿加早餐旅馆）业主构建了一个基于网页的平台，以管理他们的整个在线业务，包括他们的网站、客人沟通、预定日历，基本上为老派的 B&B 提供了一整套工具——不仅仅是 Airbnb 上的一个房间，而是这些真正关心自己房屋风格、为你做早餐
and all that stuff, everything they need to sort of enter into this modern area or era. And I was the CTO and built the entire Ruby on Rails monolithic application that ended up powering this platform. So that was super exciting. I did at the same time, you know, coming out of high school, decide to go to college. I'd already realized that I didn't necessarily need to get a job, but I did still want that sort of college opportunity.
以及所有这些事情的夫妻老店——他们融入这个现代时代所需的一切。我是 CTO，并构建了整个 Ruby on Rails 单体应用程序，该应用程序最终为这个平台提供了动力。这超级令人兴奋。与此同时，你知道的，高中毕业后，我决定去上大学。我已经意识到我并不一定需要找一份工作，但我仍然想要那种大学的机会。
And the nice thing was that most of what I had learned was already meant that I could skip a lot of studying for stuff in college. And I did get to sort of deepen my knowledge in areas like cryptography and database internals and big O notation, data structures, data algorithms, and all of that stuff, which hasn't necessarily been useful every single day in my later life in industry. But it did give me the confidence that I wasn't just making sort of newbie mistakes in writing my code without any kind of understanding of the fundamentals that made one path slowly performing and another path much more optimized.
好消息是我学到的大部分东西已经意味着我可以跳过大学里的很多课程学习。我确实得以在密码学、数据库内部机制、大 O 表示法、数据结构、数据算法等领域深化了我的知识，这些并不一定在后来的行业生涯中每天都有用。但它确实给了我信心，让我在编写代码时不仅仅是在犯新手错误，而是对那些让一条路径性能缓慢、另一条路径更加优化的基础知识有所理解。
That makes sense. How did you deal with that? I mean, so you're CTO of this company and a company is at its early stage. We're trying to find product market fit and a, and a bigger market, right. And everything like that. And you have to balance that with a full course load. And I mean, at some point you're probably thinking if this company fails, because I really wanted to pass calc three, like I kind of messed up, but on the other hand, it's like, you know, you're, once you have the college diploma you have it for life and you can go through a hundred companies you know
这说得通。你是怎么处理这个问题的？我的意思是，你是这家公司的 CTO，而公司正处于早期阶段。我们正试图找到产品与市场的契合点以及更大的市场，诸如此类。你必须在这些与繁重的课业之间寻找平衡。我的意思是，在某个时刻，你可能会想，如果这家公司失败了，因为我真的很想通过微积分 3，我好像搞砸了；但另一方面，你知道的，一旦你有了大学文凭，你就会终生拥有它，你可以经历一百家公司，
and you'll always have that college diploma you won't always have that job right so so it's like how do you how do you strike that balance i mean it's a it's a i feel like it's a really difficult situation yeah that's a really good question. Although my situation with that company, Stingo, it wasn't really the typical startup, let's co-found it, let's give it 100 hours a week, let's go for the stars. The situation was such that I was 18 and my co-founders were early 30s and early 50s. They were very different stages of their lives. 50-year-old who was essentially the CEO, he had a big background in this whole bed and breakfast world. He had a ton of connections in the Amsterdam bed and breakfast scene, essentially. So we were able to onboard a lot of users and customers through his
你将永远拥有那个大学文凭，但你不会永远拥有那份工作，对吧？所以，你是如何把握这种平衡的？我的意思是，我觉得这是一个非常困难的局面。是的，这是一个非常好的问题。虽然我在那家名为 Stingo 的公司的处境并不是那种典型的初创公司——让我们联合创立它，让我们每周投入 100 个小时，让我们冲向星辰大海。当时的情况是，我 18 岁，而我的联合创始人分别三十出头和五十出头。他们处于人生的非常不同的阶段。那个 50 岁的人基本上是 CEO，他在整个 B&B 世界有很深的背景。他在阿姆斯特丹 B&B 圈子里拥有大量的人脉。因此，我们能够通过他的
network immediately. But since we were all in these very different places in our lives, this ended up being initially bootstrapped by this guy I was just talking about. We didn't raise any venture funding or anything like that. And we all saw it a little bit more as this is a lifestyle business. We're going to spend as much time on this as we can get away with, which in my case was about 20 to 30 each week. And we were just going to build something for this market that we knew existed in Amsterdam.
网络立即吸引到大量的用户和客户。但由于我们都处于人生的这些截然不同的阶段，这家公司最初是由我刚才谈到的这个人自筹资金（bootstrapped）启动的。我们没有筹集任何风险投资或诸如此类的事情。我们都更倾向于把这看作是一个生活方式业务（lifestyle business）。我们要把尽可能多的时间花在这上面，对我的情况来说，每周大约 20 到 30 个小时。我们只是打算为这个我们知道在阿姆斯特丹确实存在的市场打造一些东西。
But actually, because of these very different places in our lives and me being eager to like, okay, let's go for it. Let's make this take off. Let's build a billion dollar company. I was eager to go all in. And they were in different situations. One of them was pretty close to retirement and starting to think about, okay, how can I cash out and like do other stuff? The other guy was, he had some kids, so he was more interested in some sort of stable income, right?
但实际上，由于我们在人生的这些截然不同的阶段，加上我渴望“好吧，让我们大干一场吧。让它腾飞吧。让我们建立一个十亿美元的公司”。我渴望全情投入。而他们处于不同的情况。其中一个人离退休很近，开始考虑“好吧，我怎么才能套现然后做点别的事情？”另一个人有一些孩子，所以他对某种稳定的收入更感兴趣，对吧？
Then instead of the high risk, high reward startup situation. And that's actually what led us to decide after about three years running that company to wind it down. And I was still in college at that time. I was also pretty active in the sort of Ruby on Rails meetups in Amsterdam and Utrecht, this college town where I went.
而不是高风险、高回报的初创公司局面。这实际上导致我们在运营该公司大约三年后决定将其关停。当时我还在上大学。我也相当积极地参与阿姆斯特丹和乌得勒支（我去的那座大学城）的 Ruby on Rails 聚会。
And through one of these and a conference that I went to in Athens, in Greece, I ended up running into this guy. His name is Sitsi Brandi. If you're very aware of companies that IPO'd last year, you might know where this story is going. But this was a guy who was building essentially a company around an open source clone of GitHub called GitLab, which was this open source project that had come up in Ukraine in around 2011. And he realized that there was a business opportunity around it to start offering support or sort of a hosted edition or enterprise editions. And at the time I met him,
通过其中一次聚会以及我去希腊雅典参加的一个会议，我偶然遇到了这个人。他的名字叫西蒂·布兰迪（Sitsi Brandi）。如果你非常了解去年进行 IPO 的公司，你可能知道这个故事将走向何方。但这个人基本上是围绕 GitHub 的一个开源克隆版建立一家公司的，这个开源项目大约在 2011 年左右在乌克兰出现。他意识到这其中存在一个商业机会，可以开始提供支持、托管版本或企业版。在我遇到他的时候，
this was just four or five people in the Netherlands. And we kept running into each other a few times. And interestingly enough, his parents had a bed and breakfast in the north of the Netherlands. So his parents became customers of this platform I had built single-handedly from the code side of things. What happened to that platform? So when you say you wound it down,
这只是荷兰的四五个人。我们偶然碰面了几次。有趣的是，他的父母在荷兰北部经营一家民宿。于是，他的父母成了我独自从代码层面构建的这个平台的客户。那个平台后来怎么了？所以当你问我它是怎么被缩减规模的，
did you sell it to another private equity or what happened? We did briefly consider looking for buyers, but we ultimately decided that since the platform was pretty much done, people were really happy with that. We could just keep those paying customers going for a number of years. So we stopped all development and we stopped onboarding new users,
你是把它卖给了一家私募股权公司，还是发生了什么？我们确实短暂考虑过寻找买家，但我们最终决定，既然这个平台已经基本完成了，大家对此也很满意，我们可以让这些付费客户继续使用好几年。所以我们停止了所有的开发，也停止了吸引新用户，
but it stayed up for a while. And it was only last year, about five years after we sort of stopped investment, that we wound it down when the user count had dropped below, you know, a mark where it wasn't sustainable anymore. But for a number of years, this was passive income, which was, of course, very nice for all of us
但它还是维持了一段时间。直到去年，大约在我们停止投资五年后，当用户数下降到一个不再可持续的门槛以下时，我们才彻底关闭了它。但在好几年里，这都是被动收入，对我们所有人来说当然都非常棒，
while we were working on new projects and new job opportunities. Oh, that makes sense. Very cool. So I met this Sitsi Brandi who was building this company called GitLab. We kept running into each other at different meetups around Europe.
当时我们正在开发新的项目和寻找新的工作机会。哦，原来如此。太酷了。我遇到了这位正在打造名为 GitLab 这家公司的 Sitsi Brandi。我们在欧洲各地的不同聚会上不断偶遇。
And eventually when I was in this position where I was looking for new products again, I reached out to him. He had already previously told me like, hey, Dawa, if you're ever interested, come see if you can come join us at GitLab. At that point, it was just one startup out of many that were sort of in my vicinity.
最终，当我再次寻找新项目的时候，我联系了他。他之前已经跟我说过，嘿，达瓦（Dawa），如果你哪天感兴趣，随时来看看能不能加入我们在 GitLab 的团队。当时，这只是我身边的众多初创公司之一。
I don't even remember exactly what it was that attracted me to the project, although open source and building something for developers was of course massively attractive being a developer myself and i ended up joining gitlab as employee number 10 just when they were going through y combinator uh that's 2015 i think while the entire team was in the mountain view house and i was you know i wasn't able to join because my professors wouldn't allow me to take that much time off. But I did get to join the company at that stage. Well, let me see if I can understand this.
我甚至不记得具体是什么吸引我加入了这个项目，尽管作为一个开发者，开源以及为开发者构建东西本身就有着巨大的吸引力。我最终以第 10 名员工的身份加入了 GitLab，当时他们正经历 Y Combinator 的孵化，我想那是 2015 年。当时整个团队都在芒廷维尤（Mountain View）的房子里，而我……你知道的，我没能加入，因为我的教授不准我请那么长时间的假。但我确实在那个阶段加入了公司。好吧，让我看看我能不能理解这一点。
So at this point, are you a bachelor student or a master student? Bachelor student. Yeah. So I originally joined GitLab part time. Got it. And so when you say you're a professor, you mean like one of the people who's teaching a course that you were taking? Yeah. One of the lecturers.
所以在这个时候，你是一名本科生还是研究生？本科生。是的。所以我最初是半工半读加入 GitLab 的。明白了。当你说你的教授时，是指教你正在修读的课程的老师之一吗？对。其中一位讲师。
Exactly. Got it. Okay. He wouldn't let you move to Mountain view and do everything remote yeah so they were pretty understanding when it came to oh you know i had to go to san francisco for a week at some point for a course that was fine but to say i'm going to take two or three months off and like i have to catch up on all of the tests afterwards we've done remotely that definitely wasn't an option at the time so you know in academics in the netherlands as well
没错。明白了。好的。他不让你搬到芒廷维尤去远程完成所有工作？是的，所以在以下方面他们还算通情理：噢，你知道的，我曾经因为一门课程需要在某个时候去旧金山待上一周，这没问题；但如果说我要请假两三个月，然后还得补上所有远程完成的测试，那在当时绝对是不可能的。所以，在荷兰的学术界也是如此，
there's a little bit of they don't quite understand sort of the tech startup industry silicon valley world of course they look up to it to a degree but they also think of it as less than because they are like professors pushing the limits and it's different than um oh no no we're not going to give you three months off to work on some startup that's not real anyway you're just going to work for some kind of consultancy in the Netherlands. That was unfortunately very much the mindset of some of the lecturers there. Not to say anything bad generally about the education. It's really great.
他们有点不太理解科技创业公司行业、硅谷的世界。当然，他们在某种程度上仰慕它，但同时也觉得它低人一等，因为他们觉得教授们是在突破极限，这跟……哦不，我们不会给你三个月的假期去搞什么创业公司，那反正不是正经事，你只会去荷兰的某种咨询公司工作。不幸的是，那里的某些讲师很大程度上就是这种心态。这并不是说对教育本身有什么不好的评价。它真的很棒。
It's just a very different attitude and focus. Yeah. I want to jump into one thing really quick. I'm assuming, so like, you know, you finish college and then you go to Mountain View to work for GitLab? No. So GitLab from day one had been an all remote company. It started as an open source project
这只是一种非常不同的态度和侧重点。好的。我想迅速切入一件事。我猜，就像你大学毕业后，然后去芒廷维尤为 GitLab 工作？不是的。所以 GitLab 从第一天起就是一家全远程公司。它最初是一个开源项目，
that was founded in Ukraine. And then they attracted open source contributors from all around the world. So there were already hundreds of active contributors by the time that this Dutch guy Sid decided, hey, there's an opportunity to build a business around this project. And at that point,
在乌克兰创立。然后他们吸引了来自世界各地的开源贡献者。所以，当这位荷兰小伙子西德（Sid）决定“嘿，围绕这个项目建立一个商业模式是个机会”时，已经有数百名活跃的贡献者了。而在那个时候，
it didn't make sense to start an office somewhere and then hire some of these contributors and ask them to move. Rather, we were a tiny little pocket of like six full-time people in this community of hundreds, and we were working with them. So we were on GitHub initially, using all of these sort of asynchronous tools to collaborate with these people, no matter where they might be. And from that day, GitLab never changed from its remote work policy. And GitLab, just before the pandemic at least, was the largest all remote company in the world with 2000 people across 68 different countries and territories. So I joined GitLab when I was still in college, still in the Netherlands, but had my team or had the team I worked on was also in the Netherlands. The rest of them were located elsewhere. And I was able to combine that with college for about a year and a half. By the time that that was done, GitLab had grown from 10 when I joined to probably 100 or so. And I stayed working there for a while from the Netherlands.
在一个地方设立办公室，然后雇佣其中一些贡献者并要求他们搬迁，是没有意义的。相反，在这个由数百人组成的社区中，我们只是一个六人全职员工的小群体，我们与他们一起工作。所以我们最初在 GitHub 上，使用所有这些异步工具来与这些人合作，无论他们身在何处。从那一天起，GitLab 就从未改变过其远程工作政策。而且 GitLab，至少在疫情爆发之前，是世界上规模最大的全远程公司，在 68 个不同的国家和地区拥有 2000 名员工。所以我加入 GitLab 时还在上大学，依然在荷兰，但我所在的团队也在荷兰。其余的人分布在其他地方。我得以将工作与大学生活结合大约一年半的时间。到那项工作完成时，GitLab 的规模已经从我加入时的 10 人增长到了大约 100 人。我继续在荷兰工作了一段时间。
But since it was all remote, I also jumped on the opportunity to go and travel and meet these colleagues around the world. So in 2016, actually, like a month after I finished my college bachelor's degree and was sort of no longer more to one particular place, I went on a six-month trip where I visited 49 of these colleagues in 20 different cities in 14 countries on five continents in the space of six months, which was just an amazing experience for myself, but also the people being visited. Getting to work with them for five days,
但由于它是完全远程的，我也抓住了去旅行并结识世界各地同事的机会。所以在 2016 年，实际上是在我完成大学本科学历的一个月后，我不再被束缚在某个特定地方，我进行了一次为期六个月的旅行，在六个月内访问了 14 个国家 20 个城市的 49 位同事，横跨五个大洲。这对我自己以及被拜访的人来说都是一次惊艳的经历。能够与他们一起工作五天，
seeing their natural habitat, their local coffee place, their home, their kids. And then taking Saturday to see the city that they lived in with an actual local tour guide. And then Sunday we would be on to the next location, which was an amazing experience. Yeah, so when you were still moored to the Netherlands, we have people listening to your show from all over the world. And a lot of them say, will write in and say
了解他们的自然栖息地、他们当地的咖啡馆、他们的家、他们的孩子。然后在周六由真正的当地导游带我游览他们居住的城市。到了周日，我们就会前往下一个地点，这真是一次美妙的经历。是的，所以当你还被束缚在荷兰时，我们的节目有来自世界各地的听众。他们中的很多人会写信说，
something like, you know, I don't live in a tech capital. You know, I don't live in San Francisco or Miami or Austin or New York or any of this. You know, how do I meet people locally, you know, and have that face to face with people who are interested in these kind of things? I think you think you, you kind of, uh, touch on a little bit of that, but what sort of advice would you give to those people who live in, and I'm not putting Kansas city down. Kansas city could be amazing, but I was just like Kansas city, you know, what, what advice would you give to, uh, to people who live in Nebraska or something? Well, I mean, I'm not going to touch, uh, any prejudices about us States, but you'll find those like-minded people if you just look hard enough. What made a really big difference for me is finding this community in that evidence called Young Creators, which was basically all high school aged kids who had somehow been a little bit more entrepreneurial than their peers.
类似于，你知道的，我不住在科技之都。你知道的，我不住在旧金山、迈阿密、奥斯汀、纽约或任何这些地方。你知道的，我如何在当地结识志同道合的人，你知道的，如何与对这类事情感兴趣的人面对面交流？我想你多多少少触及了一点，但对于那些住在……我并不是在贬低堪萨斯城。堪萨斯城可能很棒，但我只是说堪萨斯城，你知道的，你会给住在内布拉斯加州或其他地方的人什么建议？好吧，我的意思是，我对美国各州没有任何偏见，但如果你努力寻找，就会找到这些志同道合的人。对我产生巨大影响的是在荷兰找到了一个名为“年轻创造者”（Young Creators）的社区，它基本上全是由高中年龄段的孩子组成，他们不知为何比同龄人更有创业精神。
Either they've been designers or programmers or they've been starting little lemonade stands companies from a very young age. And it really wasn't until I found that group who had, I think, monthly meetups in Amsterdam at the time that I had to take like a one-hour train ride to get to until I felt, okay, I'm surrounded by people like me and we can chat about the same stuff and we have the same sort of dreams that go beyond
要么他们是设计师或程序员，要么他们很小的时候就开始经营小型柠檬水摊或公司。直到我找到那个群体——他们当时在阿姆斯特丹有月度聚会，我得坐一个小时的火车才能到达——我才觉得，好吧，我被和我一样的人包围了，我们可以聊相同的话题，我们有着超越……的同样的梦想
just the space where we grew up. And did you find that group twitter honestly like i said earlier this job opportunity at this iphone and mac development studio came just from being active in the sort of twitter ios development space and then through that i came into contact with some dutch people of course there's a good amount of like really great dutch ios developers as well so just by following those and interacting with that sort of part of the internet, I met those like-minded people. Now, Patrick, you have to make a Twitter account. See, this is why. Oh, I don't use Twitter anymore. Oh, no.
我们成长空间的梦想。你是通过 Twitter 找到那个群体的吗？老实说，就像我刚才说的，这个在 iPhone 和 Mac 开发工作室的工作机会，仅仅是因为活跃在 Twitter 的 iOS 开发领域，然后通过这个我接触到了一些荷兰人——当然，也有相当数量非常优秀的荷兰 iOS 开发人员。所以，只要关注他们并与互联网的那一部分进行互动，我就遇到了那些志同道合的人。帕特里克（Patrick），你必须注册一个 Twitter 账号。你看，这就是原因。哦，我不用 Twitter 了。哦，不。
He doesn't need it anymore. I'm off the hook. Oh, I just shot myself in the foot. So, okay, what would you do now? Let's say you were 16 years old over again, but in 2022, how would you go find those young creators nowadays? Snapchat. TikTok, apparently. I was talking to some Gen Z kids last week, and it just was, I mean, I'm 28.
他已经不需要了。我解脱了。哦，我刚搬起石头砸了自己的脚。好吧，那么你会怎么做？假设你重新回到 16 岁，但在 2022 年，你现在会如何去寻找那些年轻的创造者？Snapchat。显然还有 TikTok。我上周和一些 Z 世代的孩子交谈过，这简直是……我的意思是，我 28 岁了。
I don't think of myself as old, but I was so out of touch with whatever the world today looks like to them. So probably just TikTok. But honestly, sort of tying this back again to how GitLab also worked and how GitLab built this massive all remote team around the world, contributing to open source projects
我不认为自己老，但我对他们当今的世界是什么样子已经彻底脱节了。所以大概也就是 TikTok 吧。但老实说，再次将这一点与 GitLab 的运作方式以及 GitLab 如何在全球建立起这个庞大的全远程团队联系起来，参与开源项目
is an amazing way to interact with and sort of learn from the best and show your work to people who might actually hire you remotely. Like the first couple dozen engineers at GitLab were all open source contributors who either they applied or we reached out and said like, hey, do you want to do this full time?
是与最优秀的人互动并向他们学习，向可能实际远程雇佣你的人展示你的工作的绝佳途径。比如 GitLab 的前几十名工程师全都是开源贡献者，要么是他们申请了，要么是我们主动联系并说：嘿，你想全职做这个吗？
Because by the time that they had proven themselves with high quality contributions and really great sort of async rhythm communication skills, it was a known quantity. And it was so much easier for us to bring some of those in than to go through a whole hiring process and not know what you get. So I would say if you don't just want to meet like-minded people, but also find a way to
因为当他们通过高质量的贡献和非常棒的异步节奏沟通技巧证明了自己时，他们就是知根知底的人选。将其中一些人招募进来，要比经历一整套招聘流程却不知道会招到什么人要容易得多。所以我想说，如果你不仅想结识志同道合的人，还想找到一种途径
potentially get a job opportunity out of it, or at least build code that can sort of form your portfolio, joining the open source community for a commercial open source project is a really great way to start. And GitLab is a great example of that. But Meltano, just to sort of, you know, throw in the name of my company, is another one. It's an open source platform for data teams to work more effectively on all of their data movement and data transformation challenges with the software development best practices built in. And it's an open source Python project. And a good amount of our current team of about 17 people started out as open source contributors or generally users of this tool. And they, too, are based around the world. We don't have an office either.
潜在地获得工作机会，或者至少建立能够构成你作品集的代码，加入商业开源项目的开源社区是一个很好的开始。GitLab 就是一个极好的例子。但为了顺便提及我公司的名字，Meltano 是另一个例子。它是一个开源平台，让数据团队能够更高效地处理所有数据移动和数据转换挑战，并内置了软件开发的最佳实践。这是一个开源的 Python 项目。我们目前大约 17 人的团队中，有相当一部分人最初是开源贡献者或是该工具的用户。他们同样分布在世界各地。我们也没有办公室。
So we're very much sort of following in GitLab's footsteps there. And that's a way in which the world today is also very different from when I started, you know, in terms of job experience almost 19 years ago, when remote work was still weird and people didn't really trust paying someone across the internet. They only saw through Zoom. GitLab was a pioneer in that, the pandemic of course has made that extremely mainstream and there really is no reason for you wherever you're born not to tap into those kinds of job opportunities if you are able to get on their radar and show your work and open source
所以我们在很大程度上追随了 GitLab 的脚步。这也是当今世界与我近 19 年前刚开始时的经历截然不同的地方——当时远程工作还很怪异，人们并不真正信任通过互联网向某人付薪。他们只能通过 Zoom 看到对方。GitLab 是这方面的先驱，疫情当然让这种模式变得极其主流。无论你出生在哪里，如果你能进入他们的视线并展示你的工作，完全没有理由不去利用这种工作机会，而开源
contributions are an amazing way to do that yeah i mean the whole remote work thing is still unfolding in really interesting ways. There was an article Malcolm Gladwell wrote, I think yesterday, I mean, very recently, where he was saying, basically, he was saying remote work is unhealthy, unproductive, etc, etc. I don't agree with that at all. So let me just put my own opinion out there. But I mean, that's somebody who has a ton of respect around the world and has clearly
贡献是做到这一点的绝佳途径。是的，我的意思是，整个远程工作的事情仍在以非常有趣的方式展开。马尔科姆·格拉德威尔（Malcolm Gladwell）写过一篇文章，我想是昨天，我的意思是，非常近的一篇，他在文中基本上说，远程工作是不健康的、没有生产力的，等等等等。我完全不同意这一点。所以请允许我发表我自己的观点。但我的意思是，那是一个在全世界赢得了巨大尊重的人，并且显然
fallen on one side of the fence there. We haven't achieved any type of consensus. We're still, I think, as a global community trying to figure that out. But I do think it's fascinating. I think that, as you said, the pandemic really forced the question on the world because I think there were a lot of companies that were very against remote work and the pandemic forced them to embrace it for at least a year and so that now it's like well what do you where did they they're on much more shaky ground with
已经站在了其中一边。我们尚未达成任何共识。我认为，作为一个全球社区，我们仍在试图弄清楚这一点。但我确实觉得这很迷人。我认为，正如你所说，疫情确实将这个问题强加给了世界，因为我认为有很多公司非常反对远程工作，而疫情迫使他们至少接受了一年，以至于现在的情况是——好吧，那又怎样，他们的立场要脆弱得多，
their with that argument so um so yeah the whole thing is fascinating yeah and I mean I can talk about this some more like GitLab was and is one of the companies that had made remote work work at scale by far the best. And anyone who has worked remote during the pandemic should not think that they now know what remote work is like. It's extremely different if you set up a company intentionally from day one to be remote.
他们的那个论点也更加站不住脚。所以，嗯，整件事都很迷人。是的，我的意思是，我可以多聊聊这个，GitLab 过去是、现在也是将远程工作做到规模化的表现最好的公司之一。任何在疫情期间远程工作过的人都不应认为他们现在就了解远程工作是什么样的。如果你从第一天起就刻意将公司建立为远程办公，情况会极其不同。
You design all your processes in this sort of async compatible text-based way primarily with all kinds of processes to get that social interaction despite the geographical distribution. Very different from if a company has to suddenly change. It's not super motivated to change its way because you think it's just temporary. The people that are forced to do it didn't choose to do it. That also makes a big difference. Remote work doesn't work for everyone. It also definitely doesn't work for every industry but if you're a company that is
你会以这种异步兼容、以文本为主的方式精心设计所有的流程，并通过各种流程来克服地理分散带来的社交互动。这与一家公司被迫突然改变是截然不同的。由于你认为这只是暂时的，公司并么有太大的动力去改变自己的方式。被迫这样做的人并不是自愿选择的。这也有很大的不同。远程工作并不适合所有人。它也绝对不适合每一个行业，但如果你是一家
building software all of the tools we use the githubs the git labs the slacks the you know whatever else we have on our computers it's all built around this async stuff anyway and even if you're working on a computer you're probably in an office you're probably talking with your you know person one office over over all of these anyway. So it is an industry that is particularly well suited to it. But then also on the people side, it's really important that the people know what they're getting into and know that this would work for them. If you need that constant social interaction in order to feel connected to your company or to feel productive, then it's never going to be a good experience.
开发软件的公司——我们使用的所有工具，GitHub、GitLab、Slack，以及电脑上的其他任何东西——无论如何都是围绕这些异步东西构建的。而且即使你在电脑前工作，你大概也是在办公室里，无论如何你可能会通过所有这些工具与隔壁办公室的人交流。所以这是一个特别适合这种模式的行业。但在人员方面，同样非常重要的是，人们必须知道自己将要面对什么，并确知这适合他们。如果你需要不断的社交互动来感到与公司的联系或感到有生产力，那么这永远不会是一次美好的体验。
But if people apply for a remote work job intentionally, and they know I prefer to work from home, I want to be able to spend more time with my kids, I don't want to have a commute, and I know by myself that I'm pretty good at just working on a computer for a number of hours without seeing people, then it makes a massive difference too if everyone is sort of into it and equally bought into the concept.
但如果人们是有意申请远程工作岗位的，并且他们知道我更喜欢在家工作，我想要花更多时间陪孩子，我不想通勤，而且我自己也知道我非常擅长在电脑前工作几个小时而不见人，那么如果每个人都对此投入并同样认可这个概念，这就会带来巨大的不同。
And then also the intentionality of the processes you design and the things you introduce to balance out some of that lack of in-face-to-face interaction make a huge difference. Like at GitLab and also now at Naltano, it's so important to still have people meet occasionally.
此外，你设计的流程的刻意性，以及你为了平衡面对面互动缺失而引入的事情，会带来巨大的改变。就像在 GitLab 以及现在的 Meltano，让大家偶尔聚在一起仍然非常重要。
So every nine months, we fly the entire company into one place and we get like five days or so of quality in-person time, which really builds those relationships and that rapport and that sort of foundation of understanding on top of which you can work productively and feel like you can give each other constructive feedback
所以每隔九个月，我们会把全公司的员工飞到同一个地方，进行大约五天的面对面交流，这真的能建立起彼此的关系、默契以及理解的基础，在此基础之上，你可以高效地工作，并觉得能够给彼此提出建设性的反馈，
without being unsure about how that will be received. And then also at the same time, like I mentioned earlier, allowing people to travel and visit each other makes a huge difference. Those six months that I spent traveling around, visiting all of these colleagues, made a massive difference for me and the people being visited. And this actually turned into a policy at GitLab where if you travel to visit your colleagues the company will pay most of the time most of your travel expenses. That's a really good point. Yeah it's a really good point you know if a company isn't paying
而不用担心这会被如何解读。同时，就像我之前提到的，允许员工出差并互相拜访也会产生巨大的影响。我在各处旅行、拜访所有这些同事的那六个月，对我以及被拜访的人都产生了巨大的影响。这后来甚至成了GitLab的一项政策：如果你去拜访同事，公司会承担大部分的差旅费用。这真的是个很好的观点。是的，这真的是个很好的观点，你知道，如果一家公司不支付
to keep a desk for you somewhere that money can get redirected to these type of events which are probably much better uh you know because you're you're going with intent exactly it's intentional so yeah you save money from the office you save money from you know all the humanities you need to have there you save people time because of the lack of commutes and you can make up for all of this in doing these one-off events and funding the social interaction that just does need to take place. So that six-month trip is something that became a policy and a lot of people in GitLab started doing where they did like a Euro trip and then they visited, you know, however many people over the course of three months.
把给你的办公桌省下来的资金重新分配给这类活动，这可能要好得多，你知道的，因为你们是带着目的去的，没错，这就是有目的性的。所以，是的，你节省了办公室的费用，节省了你需要在那儿提供的各种福利的费用，由于不用通勤，你也为人们节省了时间，而且你可以通过举办这些一次性活动以及资助那些确实需要发生的社交互动来弥补这一切。因此，那个为期六个月的旅行变成了一项政策，GitLab 的许多人开始这样做：他们会进行一次欧洲行，然后在三个月的时间里拜访，嗯，任意数量的人。
And in every city where we ended up having a significant amount of people, like five plus, we ended up having monthly co-working days where everyone from that region would just come in one Friday of the month, work together for the whole day and then have a shared group dinner and this also just meant that the people in our region felt great yeah where would they go we would rent a co-working space or some kind of meeting room somewhere and just all be sitting around a meeting space together and then you know go to a restaurant and of course this would be covered by the company as well because it is part of that social fabric that is really valuable to making a company work at scale. And then combining these two things, the travel and these co-working days, you ended up having people do a Euro trip where they would try to hit all of the co-working days they could within the time that they were traveling. amsterdam brussels lisbon you know rome um and visit seven different european countries with a
在我们最终拥有大量员工（比如五人以上）的每个城市，我们最终都会举办每月的联合办公日，该地区的每个人都会在每月的某个星期五聚在一起，一整天都在一起工作，然后进行一次共享的团队晚宴，这也意味着我们地区的员工感觉很棒。是的，他们会去哪儿呢？我们会租一个联合办公空间或某个地方的某种会议室，然后大家一起坐在一个会议空间里，接着，你知道的，去餐馆，当然，这也将由公司承担，因为它是让公司大规模运转的真正宝贵的社交结构的一部分。然后将这两件事结合起来，即旅行和这些联合办公日，你最终会让人进行一次欧洲行，他们会在旅行期间尝试赶上他们能参加的所有联合办公日。阿姆斯特丹、布鲁塞尔、里斯本、罗马，嗯，参观七个不同的欧洲国家，基本上还有
local tour guide basically to show you around and this opportunity to immediately meet 10 plus people there and that's stuff that made it work which of course during the pandemic was impossible because no one could see each other at all so all these folks all you folks out there who are going for your bachelor's right now and you're taking algorithms and data structures too and you're learning about traveling salesmen and you're like i will never use the traveling salesman problem you might find yourself at gila needing to go eat like uh drink beers at four different cities in a month yeah yeah exactly it's uh it's not bad but of course it not only gets up anymore which is great there's so many remote only companies now or remote first or you know remote compatible although we do believe that the hybrid model doesn't work nearly as well as the all remote model or the all in office model
一个当地的导游带你四处参观，并且有机会立即在那里结识 10 多个人，正是这些东西让它得以运作，这在疫情期间当然是不可能的，因为根本没有人能见到彼此，所以所有这些在座的、目前正在攻读学士学位、同时也在学习算法和数据结构、并且正在了解旅行商问题并觉得“我永远不会用到旅行商问题”的朋友们，你们可能会发现自己身处 Meltano，需要在一个月内在四个不同的城市去喝啤酒，没错，没错，确切地说，这并不坏，但当然，它不仅不再存在，这太棒了，现在有那么多纯远程公司，或者是远程优先，或者你知道的，远程兼容的公司，尽管我们确实相信混合办公模式的运作效果远不如全远程模式或全办公室模式
because with the hybrid thing you do have sort of a tier system where the people who get to actually see their boss face to face every day just do have higher chance of promotions and stuff because it does make a difference for that foundation of trust. But if everyone is in the same exact spot, it works much better. But there's a lot of companies now, and if you look at like the most recent YC, Y Combinator batch of startups, a good percentage of those are just all remote
因为在混合办公的情况下，你确实会有一种阶层系统，那些实际上能够每天与老板面对面交流的人确实拥有更高的晋升机会等等，因为这确实对建立信任基础产生了影响。但是，如果每个人都在完全相同的地点，它的效果就会好得多。但现在有很多公司，如果你看看最近的 YC（Y Combinator）创业公司批次，其中很大一部分都只是全远程的
because why not? And why limit yourself to only the talent that is willing to move to one particular metro area if you could hire everyone from around the US or even from around the globe or from around a certain time zone. At Meltano, our team is distributed between Mexico where I'm based,
因为为什么不呢？如果你可以从全美甚至全球或某个特定时区招聘所有人，为什么要将自己局限于只愿意搬到一个特定大都市区的人才呢？在 Meltano，我们的团队分布在我所在的墨西哥、
the US, Canada, the UK, Germany. And we're willing to keep adding places to that as long as we have enough time zone overlap where we can make it work. And there's a lot of companies doing that now, including a number of them founded by fellow GitLab alumni like myself. and actually Sid, his next project essentially after GitLab is this open core venture capital firm where they specifically invest in open core, which means open source
美国、加拿大、英国、德国。只要我们有足够能够让其运作的时区重叠，我们就愿意继续在其中增加地点。现在有很多公司都在这样做，其中包括许多由像我这样的 GitLab 校友创立的公司。事实上，西德（Sid）在 GitLab 之后的下一个项目基本上是这家开源风险投资公司，他们专门投资开源核心，这意味着开源
projects with a commercial business model around them. And a good amount of those are starting out remote as well. So yeah, it's a fascinating space. And GitLab has, you know, we've been front runners on both the fields of commercial open source and remote work for years now. And that's all stuff that we bring into Meltano as well. Cool. So that's a good way to pivot to the topic at hand, which is data ops.
且周围围绕着商业商业模式的项目。其中相当一部分也是从远程开始的。所以，是的，这是一个迷人的领域。而且多年来，GitLab 一直是商业开源和远程办公这两个领域的领跑者。这也是我们带给 Meltano 的所有东西。太好了，所以这是过渡到当前主题（即数据运营）的一个好方法。
So when you were at, you went from GitLab to Meltano, but when you're at GitLab, you must have seen something that made you say DataOps is really important. Was DataOps like a cornerstone to GitLab success or what's the connection there? Yeah, the connection is a strong connection. So it was actually not me who realized the opportunity in DataOps. It was a number of people in GitLab who were seeing how the data team at GitLab was working and the kind of tools they were using and how far away that seemed to be from the types of workflows and collaboration tools available to the software developers working at GitLab. And of course, also using GitLab itself, since it was a product, you know, it's a software development collaboration platform, essentially a DevOps platform. And it was realized that in this data space, these people are technical enough, and they
那么，当你在时，你从 GitLab 转到了 Meltano，但是当你在 GitLab 时，你一定见过某些东西，让你觉得 DataOps 真的非常重要。DataOps 是 GitLab 成功的基石吗？或者它们之间有什么联系？是的，这种联系非常紧密。所以实际上并不是我意识到了 DataOps 中的机遇。是 GitLab 的许多人看到了 GitLab 的数据团队是如何工作的、他们使用的是什么工具、以及这似乎与 GitLab 软件开发人员可用的工作流程和协作工具类型相差多远。当然，也使用 GitLab 本身，因为它是一个产品，你知道的，它是一个软件开发协作平台，本质上是一个 DevOps 平台。人们意识到，在这个数据领域，这些人具有足够的技术能力，并且他们
have similar enough needs of collaboration and high reliability and stability and being confident in the results of their work, that applying more of these software development best practices to the work that data teams do could make them a lot more efficient, effective, and really sort of level up that whole profession. And it was uniquely GitLab who realized the opportunity for open source and DevOps best practices applied to the data space. And it was in 2018 that a dedicated team was set up inside GitLab to essentially build a better data platform for the GitLab data team that would maybe eventually,
有着足够相似的协作、高可靠性、高稳定性以及对工作结果充满信心的需求，将更多这些软件开发最佳实践应用到数据团队所做的工作中，可以使他们效率更高、成效更好，并且真正提升整个行业的水平。正是 GitLab 独具慧眼，意识到了将开源和 DevOps 最佳实践应用于数据领域的机遇。正是在 2018 年，GitLab 内部成立了一个专门的团队，本质上是为 GitLab 数据团队构建一个更好的数据平台，这个平台可能最终，
initially as an open source project, maybe eventually become an open source business in its own right. So let's unpack that. What is the data team at GitLab? What does that mean? What is the skill set? What does people do? Yeah, good question. So people have been saying things like data is the new oil or whatever else people have been saying in these very nondescript phrases that do sort of signal the importance of it. If you're a company, you're trying to, or if you're any organization, really, you're trying to accomplish something, you have goals. And you want to know what the right way or the best way is to get to that goal. You also want to see how well are we currently doing
最初作为一个开源项目，最终可能会发展成为一个独立的开源商业业务。那么让我们来剖析一下。GitLab 的数据团队是什么？这意味着什么？技能组合是什么？人们都在做什么？是的，好问题。所以人们一直在说“数据是新的石油”之类的话，或者人们在这些非常笼统的短语中一直在说的其他话，这些短语确实在某种程度上表明了它的重要性。如果你是一家公司，你正试图，或者如果你是任何组织，实际上，你正试图完成某项任务，你就有目标。并且你想知道实现该目标的正确方法或最佳方法是什么。你还想看看我们目前的表现如何
or how am I even going to measure my success? And being able to measure your success and being able to come up with a plan where you're pretty confident that this is probably the best way to get there requires you to look at the data and make predictions based on where you are now and what you see in the data as big opportunities and giving yourself some kind of goal to go after.
或者我将如何衡量我的成功？能够衡量你的成功，并能够提出一个计划，让你相当确信这可能是实现目标的最佳途径，这就需要你查看数据，并根据你现在的处境以及你在数据中看到的重大机遇做出预测，并为自己设定某种要追求的目标。
And this is the same whether you are an educational institution or you're a non-profit or you're a massive company that's just looking at the bottom line. In any way, the more you learn from the data available to you to tell you how well you're currently doing and how much better you could be doing, the better. So in a company like GitLab, which is an online SaaS platform with a ton of users and of course also a product and it has a marketing arm, some of the data you're talking about is just usage of the product itself. Like which features are people using?
无论你是一个教育机构、一个非营利组织，还是一个只看重利润的庞大公司，情况都是一样的。无论如何，你从可用数据中了解到的关于你目前表现得有多好以及你可以表现得有多好的信息越多，就越好。因此，在像 GitLab 这样的一家公司中，它是一个拥有大量用户、当然还有一个产品并拥有营销部门的在线 SaaS 平台，你所讨论的一些数据只是产品本身的使用情况。比如人们正在使用哪些功能？
If they use this feature, do they make it to the next step? Are there features that are not seeing any use at all? What are the flows people take through the product to find particular corners of the product? How can we surface those more effectively to make people get more value out of them? Or something like A-B testing, where you don't know quite yet which way of talking about something or which way of presenting a feature is going to get most people value out of it. You want to be able to compare those.
如果他们使用了这个功能，他们会进入下一步吗？是否有根本无人使用的功能？人们通过产品找到产品的特定角落时所走的操作流程是怎样的？我们如何才能更有效地展现这些内容，让人们从中获得更多价值？或者像 A/B 测试这样，你还不太确定哪种谈论某事的方式或哪种呈现功能的方式能为大多数人带来价值。你希望能够对这些进行比较。
Or with marketing, if you have a Facebook ads campaign or you have Google ads or whatever you might have, you want to be able to measure the impact of those. Like, did this specific phrasing actually lead to more users? Did advertising alongside this type of TikTok content or whatever work better than other type of content? You want to be able to compare that and use that data. And similarly, when you're talking about your customer base, you want to learn, is there a particular segment of the industry that has a
或者在营销方面，如果你有一个 Facebook 广告活动，或者你有谷歌广告，或者你可能拥有的任何其他广告，你都希望能够衡量这些广告的影响。比如，这种特定的措辞是否真的带来了更多的用户？在这类 TikTok 内容或其他内容旁边打广告是否比其他类型的内容效果更好？你希望能够进行比较并使用这些数据。同样，当你谈论你的客户群时，你会想要了解：行业中是否存在某个特定细分市场，其
far shorter time to close than another? And should we double down on those? Or do we see that people with particular characteristics are far more likely to churn and stop paying us at some point? So this means that you have this data that could help you as a company be successful in all of these different tools like Zendesk or HubSpot when it's about support or CRM stuff, or in your own product and you might be using a platform like Mixpanel to track that data, or even if you want to track the efficiency or the happiness of the employees within your company just to sort of make sure that you're not falling short there. These are a ton of data sources, and it's up to the data team to build all the pipelines that get the data from all of these different APIs or databases and bring them into a place where analysis can take place. And analysis uses a tool, a BI, business intelligence tool, that allows you, usually with SQL, to write these queries and build these little dashboards that show you
达成交易的时间比其他细分市场要短得多？我们是否应该加大对这些细分市场的投入？或者我们是否发现具有特定特征的人更有可能流失并在某个时候停止向我们付费？这意味着你拥有这些数据，它们可以帮助你作为一个公司在所有这些不同的工具中取得成功，例如用于支持或 CRM 事务的 Zendesk 或 HubSpot，或者在你自己的产品中，你可能会使用像 Mixpanel 这样的平台来跟踪这些数据，或者即使你想跟踪公司内部员工的效率或幸福感，只是为了确保你没有在这方面有所欠缺。这些有成吨的数据源，而数据团队的任务就是构建所有的管道，将来自所有这些不同 API 或数据库的数据获取过来，并将它们汇集到一个可以进行分析的地方。分析会使用一个工具，即 BI（商业智能）工具，它允许你（通常使用 SQL）编写这些查询并构建这些小仪表盘，向你展示
how you're doing on certain metrics. But these first steps in the process are data movement and data transformation. Getting this data from all the places where it's currently hidden, getting it out usually through APIs or file dumps in FTP folders or S3 buckets or something. And then transformation means taking that raw data schema, which was optimized for an application, into a schema that is more appropriate for analysis. And for the types of questions you want to ask it and the types of queries you want to run against it, being able to do those effectively often requires you to change the schema and transform the data in a way to aggregate things or to de-anonymize things also, for example, in case you don't want to mess with PII.
你在某些指标上的表现如何。但这个流程中的前几步是数据移动和数据转换。将这些数据从目前隐藏它们的所有地方提取出来，通常通过 API 或 FTP 文件夹中的文件转储或 S3 存储桶等方式将它们拿出来。然后，转换意味着将针对应用程序进行了优化的原始数据模式，转变为更适合分析的模式。对于你想要向其提出的问题类型以及你想要针对它运行的查询类型，能够有效地完成这些操作通常需要你更改模式并以某种方式转换数据，以便聚合内容或进行去匿名化处理（例如，以防你不想处理 PII）。
So this challenge of data movement and transformation has been known for decades, but the tools used to do it are, from the eyes of a software developer, still pretty... I mean, it feels like legacy tooling. It feels like when I was nine years old and I was building a website and I would FTP into the web server and make live changes to PHP files and then go check in the browser just to see I didn't break something. So you're always working in production. Every change you make could immediately affect the user go check in the browser just to see I didn't break something. So you're always working in production. Every change you make could immediately affect the user. And in the case of the data world, that means that if you hit the save button, you might accidentally break the dashboard that your CFO is about to present to the board or the
所以，数据移动和转换这个挑战已经存在了几十年，但在软件开发人员眼中，用于完成这项工作的工具仍然相当……我的意思是，感觉就像是遗留工具。感觉就像我九岁时正在建立一个网站，我会通过 FTP 连接到网络服务器，对 PHP 文件进行实时更改，然后去浏览器里检查，以确保我没有弄坏什么东西。所以你总是在生产环境中工作。你所做的每一个更改都可能直接影响用户，去浏览器里检查，以确保我没有弄坏什么东西。所以你总是在生产环境中工作。你所做的每一个更改都可能直接影响用户。在数据世界的情况下，这意味着如果你点击保存按钮，你可能会不小心弄坏你的首席财务官正准备向董事会展示的仪表盘，或者是
thing that the CEO is looking at to make sure what it should be worried about today. And that approach of just hitting the save button and crossing your fingers, as a software development community, we've moved past that with DevOps, version control, continuous integration and deployment. And all of these best practices could also really help data teams. And it was GitLab that saw that opportunity and started building that for its own data team, who, of course, had been especially exposed to how software development teams worked and realized like, hey, we want some of that. So in 2018, the team in Getlast started working on this tooling. In 2019, I ended up joining that project as development lead when there were four engineers and a general manager on the Meltano project.
首席执行官正在查看的东西，用来确保今天应该担心什么。而这种只需点击保存按钮并祈祷好运的方法，作为一个软件开发社区，我们已经通过 DevOps、版本控制、持续集成和部署超越了这一点。所有这些最佳实践也可以真正帮助数据团队。正是在 GitLab，他们看到了这个机会，并开始为自己的数据团队构建这个工具，当然，该团队尤其接触过软件开发团队的工作方式，并意识到：嘿，我们也想要那样。所以在 2018 年，GitLab 的团队开始开发这个工具。2019 年，当 Meltano 项目有四名工程师和一个总经理时，我最终作为开发主管加入了该项目。
And in 2020, the headcount of that project was brought down from six down to one because we hadn't quite been hitting the numbers and the growth numbers and the contributor activity that we were looking for so i was left by myself on the meltano team and throughout 2020 i managed to identify a more narrow sort of description of the problem we solved and a way to really reach the audience we wanted to find and it was through 2020 that this started taking off as an open source project with hundreds and thousands of users. And in early 2021, we spun it out as an independent startup from GitLab with
而在 2020 年，该项目的员工人数从 6 人缩减到了 1 人，因为我们没有完全达到我们所期望的数字、增长数字以及贡献者活跃度，所以我被独自留在了 Meltano 团队。在整个 2020 年，我设法确定了对我们所解决的问题更狭义的描述，以及真正接触到我们想要找到的受众的方法，正是在 2020 年，这个开源项目开始起飞，拥有了成百上千的用户。在 2021 年初，我们将其从 GitLab 剥离为一个独立的初创公司，
seed funding from GV, formerly known as Google Ventures. And since then, we've been on our own independent startup journey. We raised money again this year, and we are really sort of building out this massive vision of building data tooling that that adopts from the ground up all of these things that have made the development teams software teams
获得了来自 GV（原名 Google Ventures）的种子资金。从那时起，我们一直在踏上自己独立的创业之旅。我们在今年再次筹集了资金，并且我们真的在构建一个宏大的愿景，即构建从头开始采用所有这些使开发团队、软件团队变得如此高效的特性的数据工具
so effective and we're seeing a lot of interest in that fortunately yeah so so let's double click on this so it's a data engineer or is that is that a orthogonal thing no so data engineer is one of the titles that's most common for these people that are challenged or tasked with these data movement and transformation challenges so our target audience are data engineers exactly got it i see so so someone writes an app like we can go back to your days making iphone apps right someone makes some iphone app they're writing all this objective c they're writing they're creating ns objects they're wondering why there's NSs everywhere.
幸运的是，我们看到了对此的极大兴趣，是的。所以，让我们深入探讨一下：这是一个数据工程师，还是一个正交的事情？不，所以数据工程师是那些面临或承担这些数据移动和转换挑战的人最常见的头衔之一，所以我们的目标受众正是数据工程师，明白了，我懂了。所以，有人编写了一个应用程序，就像我们可以回到你制作 iPhone 应用程序的日子一样，对吧？有人制作了一个 iPhone 应用程序，他们编写了所有这些 Objective-C，他们编写了这些代码，他们正在创建 NS 对象，他们想知道为什么到处都是 NS。
And then they send their app out and it gets, you know, three stars or two stars or one star. And people say, oh, you know, it's crashing all the time. So now some of that app will provide. So Apple has the crash handler and you can go and look at the logs and everything. So you fix all the crashes. You say, OK, I'm done. Now you get instead of getting one star,
然后他们把他们的应用发布出去，它得到了，你知道的，三星、两星或一星。人们说，哦，你知道的，它一直在崩溃。所以现在应用的一部分会提供。因此，Apple 有崩溃处理程序，你可以去查看日志和所有内容。所以你修复了所有的崩溃。你说，好吧，我完成了。现在，你得到的不是一星，
you get two stars. They're like, okay, the app is stable, but it's just not what I wanted. And so you have to sift through these reviews. It's pretty painful. And you've already kind of lost a big opportunity there, right? So that is bad. That is not the way to launch an app.
而是两星。他们会说，好吧，应用是稳定的，但它根本不是我想要的。所以你必须筛选这些评论。这挺痛苦的。而且你已经在那里失去了很大的机会，对吧？所以这很糟糕。这不是发布应用的方法。
But a better way to launch an app would be to start some really limited beta, call it a dark launch, where you don't do a lot of advertising or anything. You get a few people, and now you don't just want their reviews, because a lot of people won't write reviews. You might get everyone writing about the same complaint. You want to get really in-depth data. Did they see which of my screens in my app did they look at? If nobody looked at screen four, well, why did I even build it, right? Or maybe I can't get to screen four, you know, whatever. You know, if everyone's spending all their time on screen two, that's
但发布应用的一个更好方法是开始一些非常有限的 beta 测试，称之为暗发布（dark launch），你不会做大量的广告或任何事情。你找几个人，现在你不仅想要他们的评论，因为很多人不会写评论。你可能会让每个人都写下相同的投诉。你想要获得非常深入的数据。他们看到了吗？他们看了我应用中的哪个屏幕？如果没有人看屏幕四，嗯，那我为什么还要构建它呢？对吧？或者也许我无法进入屏幕四，你知道的，不管怎样。你知道，如果每个人都把所有时间花在屏幕二上，那这就是
what I need to spend my time as a developer focused on, right? And so you can continue to like subdivide and subdivide and subdivide down to more and more nuanced data. What are people in Mexico City doing? What are people in Texas doing? And so you end up asking all of these questions and needing to slice in all these different axes, right? And so that is the sort of business value of kind of data ops and data engineering. I'll say of the whole data engineering, data science kind of process, right? And so then data engineers and data scientists are going off and trying to build the infrastructure and sort of the semantics to answer those questions. But you're saying they're doing it an equivalent of like us, you know, SSHing into a machine and like doing all the coding in nano or something, right? So yeah, I'm touching the production code, a production system all the time. Like, oops, I forgot a semicolon. And now everyone who goes to my website just gets a error 500 for the next like three minutes until I realize, right? And so Meltano is an attempt
我作为开发人员需要集中精力花时间的地方，对吧？因此，你可以继续像这样细分、细分、再细分，直到获得越来越细致的数据。墨西哥城的人在做什么？得克萨斯州的人在做什么？因此，你最终会提出所有这些问题，并需要在所有这些不同的轴上进行切片，对吧？这就是 DataOps 和数据工程的某种商业价值。我要说的是整个数据工程、数据科学这一类过程的价值，对吧？因此，然后数据工程师和数据科学家出发去尝试构建基础设施和某种语义来回答这些问题。但你说他们这样做相当于我们，你知道的，通过 SSH 连接到机器，然后用 nano 或其他东西完成所有的编码，对吧？所以，是的，我一直在触碰生产代码、生产系统。就像，哎呀，我漏了一个分号。现在所有访问我网站的人在接下来的大约三分钟内都会得到一个 500 错误，直到我意识到，对吧？所以 Meltano 试图
to make it more productive and safer to answer all of those questions we just talked about. Today's sponsor is Mergify. Mergify is a tool for GitHub that prioritizes, tunes, automatically merges, comments, rebases, updates, labels, backports, closes and assigns your pull requests. Mergeify features allow you to automate what you would normally do manually.
使回答我们刚刚讨论的所有问题变得更有成效、更安全。今天的赞助商是 Mergify。Mergify 是一个用于 GitHub 的工具，它可以优先排序、调整、自动合并、评论、变基、更新、打标签、回移植、关闭和分配你的拉取请求。Mergify 的功能允许你自动化那些你通常需要手动完成的操作。
You can secure your code using a merge queue, automatically merge it, and many more features. By saving time, you and your team can focus on projects that matter. Mergify can coordinate with any CI and is fully integrated into GitHub. They have a startup program that could give your company a 12-month credit to leverage Mergify. That's up to $21,000 of value. Start saving time. Visit Mergify.com to sign up for a demo and get started. Or just follow the link in the show notes.
你可以使用合并队列保护你的代码，自动合并它以及更多功能。通过节省时间，你和你的团队可以专注于重要的项目。Mergify 可以与任何 CI 协调，并且完全集成到 GitHub 中。他们有一个初创公司计划，可以为你的公司提供 12 个月的信用额度来利用 Mergify。这高达 21,000 美元的价值。开始节省时间。访问 Mergify.com 注册演示并开始使用。或者直接点击节目说明中的链接。
Back to the episode. Is that a good summary? Yeah, that's a really great summary. I would say, you know, you started talking about, you know, new app, dark launch. Of course, the more data you're working with, the more valuable it will be to try to automate this with processes and have data engineers that write pipelines rather than just going in manually and doing the things that don't scale. But yeah, definitely. By the time you have a lot of data like that and you actually have processes or people in your company relying on it, you also want to make sure that when you make a change, you don't accidentally break the thing that's live. And you don't then want to have to scramble to fix it live because then you're even more likely to make mistakes or not fix it in the best way. And data teams that are becoming more and more relied on
回到本期节目。这是一个很好的总结吗？是的，这是一个非常棒的总结。我想说，你知道的，你开始谈论新应用、暗发布。当然，你处理的数据越多，尝试通过流程使之自动化并拥有编写管道而不是仅仅手动进入并做那些无法扩展的事情的数据工程师，就会越有价值。但是，是的，绝对的。当你拥有大量这样 Data 的数据，并且你的公司中实际上有流程或人员依赖它时，你还想确保当你进行更改时，不会意外破坏正在线上运行的东西。然后你就不想为了修复它而手忙脚乱地进行线上修复，因为那样你更有可能犯错，或者无法以最佳方式修复它。而且数据团队正变得越来越受到其业务的依赖，
by their business, and sometimes this data is also fed back into machine learning processes or just goes back into other company systems and it kind of spreads within the network of all the connected parts of the business. If there's a mistake in there, it's a problem. And if you are hitting save and crossing
有时这些数据也会反馈到机器学习过程中，或者只是流回其他公司系统，它会在业务所有互联部分的网络中传播。如果其中出现错误，那就是个问题。如果你只是点击保存并祈祷不要破坏任何东西，在这个时代这根本行不通。在软件开发中，这很大程度上已经得到了解决。我们知道许多你可以引入团队以提供帮助的工作流程、实践和工具。目标是一样的。你希望对线上运行的任何东西都充满高度信心。你希望能够安全地进行实验，在本地尝试各种东西，在你的 Git 仓库中拥有包含实验的功能分支，并且不觉得你必须限制自己不去进行更改，因为你可能会不小心做出无法再工作的操作。甚至能够回滚到密码转换在当今存在的许多数据工具中也不是理所当然的。因此，如果你今天正在构建管道，
your fingers and hoping to break something, that just doesn't work anymore in this day and age. And in software development, a lot of this has been solved. We know a lot of the things you can introduce, workflows, practices, tools into Teams to help. And the goals are the same. You want to have high confidence in whatever is live. You want to be able to experiment safely, try stuff out locally, have the feature branches in your Git repo with experiments, and not feel like you have to limit yourself from making changes because you might accidentally do something you cannot work anymore. Even being able to roll back to a password conversion is not a given in a lot of the data tooling that exists today. So if you are building a pipeline
特别是如果你来自软件开发背景，拥有一个可以进行版本控制的东西以及一个可以通过 CI/CD 告诉你是否会意外破坏某些东西的东西，似乎是一个无需多想的决定。这提高了致力于解决这些挑战的团队的效率、效能、速度和创新能力，就像我们在软件领域中看到的一样。Mergify 的方法是，我们已经确定，针对数据生命周期的不同步骤，有很多非常优秀的开源工具。但这些工具本身并不一定拥抱软件开发最佳实践。并且在你的整个数据平台或数据栈的级别上，当你将
today, especially if you are coming from a software development background, it seems like a no-brainer to have something that can be version controlled and something where you can have CICD tell you if you are accidentally going to break something. And this increases the efficiency, effectiveness, velocity, and innovation of the team that is working to solve these challenges, same as we've seen in software. And Meltano's approach is one in which we have identified that there are a lot of really great open source tools for different steps of the data lifecycle. But these tools themselves don't necessarily embrace the software development best practices. And at the level of your entire data platform or your data stack, when you're putting together
这三四个共同解决数据移动和转换问题的工具组合在一起时，没有办法以版本控制的方式管理它们的配置，也没有办法管理跨多个工具的更改。如果你需要更新如何从某些 SaaS API 获取数据的配置，并且同时你想要修改你的转换脚本，你希望同时进行这些操作，并且你希望能够验证这种组合更改没有破坏某些东西。你无法孤立地看到这些，但数据工程的当前世界期望这些更改彼此完全独立，而这根本不是现实，因此 Meltano 允许你将数据平台的方方面面从头到尾汇集在一起，所有
these three or four tools that together solve the data movement and transformation problem, there's no way to manage their configuration in a version controlled way or to manage changes that span multiple tools. If you need to update the configuration for how to get data out of some SaaS API, and at the same time you want to modify your transformation script, you want to do that at the same time and you want to be able to validate that that combined change didn't break something. You cannot see those in isolation, but the current world in data engineering expects those changes to be fully separate from themselves from each other and that is just not the reality so meltano allows you to bring together every aspect of your data platform from start to finish and all
这些用于沿途解决渐进式问题的不同工具都集中在一个地方，并采用一致的版本控制、配置管理和端到端测试方法。因此，如果我正在与数据工程师交谈，我将在特定好处的背景下解释所有这些，因为我们不能指望他们已经了解所有这些软件开发术语。但是，如果你是一名软件开发人员，并且在你的新公司里，你看到你的数据团队在他们的工作面前手忙脚乱，如果你想让他们像你作为软件开发人员一样高效，那么 Meltano 就是能帮助他们做到这一点的工具。是的，这讲得通。所以回到我们的应用示例，我们有，比方说成千上万的人在运行我们的应用，对吧？
these different tools that you use to solve uh sort of the incremental problems along the way in one place with a consistent approach to version control, configuration management, and end-to-end testing. So if I'm talking to a data engineer, I would explain all of this in context of the specific benefits because we cannot expect them to already know all of these software development terms. But if you are a software developer and at your new company, you see your data team scrambling with their work, if you want to make them as effective as you have been as a software developer, then Meltano is the tool that will help them do so. Yeah, that makes sense. So going back to our app example, so we have, you know, let's say thousands of people running our app, right?
因此，我们希望来自所有这些人的数据都在同一个地方，以便我们可以进行所有这些分析。所以，请带我们了解一下，你知道的，那个地方是什么样的，以便我们可以进行所有这些分析。所以，请带我们了解一下，你知道的，那是什么样子的。那么我们如何从我应用中的 NS log 走到，你知道的，我们都有一个带每个人数据的仪表盘呢？数据工程师使用什么工具？那是什么样子的？是的，我没有在 iOS 生态系统中待足够长的时间，无法确切知道如何将该 NS log 语句放入某种 SaaS 产品中。但从 Meltano 的角度，或者从数据工程师的角度来看，它通常开始于：我们想要的这些信息已经存在于某种 SaaS 系统中了。这可能是，你知道的，Apple 自己的错误崩溃报告
And so we want the data from all of them, you know, in one place so that we could do all this analysis. So kind of walk us through, you know, what that place so that we could do all this analysis. So kind of walk us through, you know, what that looks like. So how do we go from NS log in my app to, you know, we all have a we have a some dashboard with everyone's data on it. What are the tools that data engineers use? What does that look like? Yeah, so I haven't been in the iOS ecosystem for long enough to exactly know how to get that NS log statement into some kind of SaaS product. But where it usually starts from the Miltana perspective, or for the data engineer perspective, is that this information we want already lives in some kind of SaaS system. So that might be, you know, Apple's own error crash report
某种界面，希望它有一个 API，如果没有，那就是功能请求。然后下一步是，我如何把它弄出来？所以，当然，你可以学习 API 文档，编写你自己的小型 Python 脚本，
sort of interface, which hopefully has an API, if not feature requests. And then the next step is, how do I get that out? So you can, of course, learn the API documentation, write your own little Python scripts
或者你喜欢的任何语言，但 Python 可以说是数据世界的通用语。然后把这些数据提取出来。接着你想把它放进一个数据仓库中，这个数据仓库不仅仅是一个像 Postgres 或 MySQL 这样的数据库，而是专门针对分析工作负载和用例进行了优化的数据库。我们称这些为 OLAP 数据库。数据仓库的一个例子是什么？是的，所以 BigQuery，Google BigQuery 是一个很大的。Amazon Redshift 是另一个。但随后 Snowflake 在过去十年左右真正以风暴般的速度席卷了世界。这就是我们看到我们的用户使用最多的东西。
or whatever language you like, but Python is sort of the lingua franca of the data world. And then pull out that data. And then you want to get into it, into a data warehouse, which is not just a database like Postgres or MySQL, but it is specifically optimized
因此，它是一个针对运行需要更多计算的分析查询进行了优化的数据库。它们非常复杂。例如，有成吨成吨的连接（joins）。它仍然是 SQL，但在底层，它需要更复杂的 SQL。因此引擎更好。它们是列式数据存储。所以它们不按行存储数据。
for analytical workloads and use cases. And we call those OLAP databases. What's an example of a data warehouse? Yeah, so BigQuery, Google BigQuery is a big one. Amazon Redshift is another. But then Snowflake has really taken over the world by storm over the last decade or so. And that is what we see our users using most.
它们按列存储数据。因此，如果你对某一列进行聚合，所有这些数据的内存局部性要高得多，因为它实际上是全部打包在一起的，而不是分散在这些具有到每行不同偏移量的行中。它将列而不是行
So it is a database that's optimized for running analytical queries that require a lot more compute. They're really complicated. Tons and tons of joins, for example. It's still SQL, but under the hood, it's expecting more complicated SQL. And so the engine is better. They're columnar data stores. So they don't store data in rows.
作为存储事物的首要方式。但带有某些扩展的 SQL（然后这些扩展取决于你正在使用的特定框架或平台）仍然是将这些数据提取出来的主语言。是的。明白了，我懂了。所以我们有某种方法将数据从（你知道的，它可以是一个网站、一个应用、无论什么、一个电子游戏、无论它是什么）获取到这个数据仓库中，对于最终用户来说，它类似于一个数据库，但在底层，对于我们接下来想要做的事情要高效得多。然后，一旦我们将所有东西都放进数据仓库里，会发生什么？是的，所以明确地说，你可以像我刚才描述的那样，编写你自己的小脚本从 Apple Crash Report API 获取数据并将其加载到你的数据仓库中。但这是一个被称为提取和加载（extract and load）或者数据移动、数据集成、数据摄取的问题。
They store data per column. So if you do aggregation over a column, all of that data is already, the memory locality is much higher because it's literally all packed together instead of being spread out over these rows with different offsets into each row. It has sort of the columns instead of the rows
这些是你想在谷歌上搜索的术语，许多公司试图通过为不同的数据仓库、不同的 SaaS API 构建这些连接器，并让你支付某种订阅费用来完成这项工作，从而解决这个问题。因此，Mergify 的不同之处之一在于，我们拥有一个针对数据源的开源连接器库，如今支持的各种来源和目的地已经超过 300 个。这个标准被称为 Singer（实际上是以缝纫机命名的），
as the primary way of storing things. But SQL with some extensions, which are then dependent on the specific framework you're using or platform you're using, is still the main language to pull this data out. Yes. Got it. I see. So we have some way of getting the data from, you know, it could be a website, an app, from whatever, a video game, from whatever it is into this data warehouse, which is similar to a database as an end user, but under the hood, much more efficient for what we want to do next. And then what happens once we have everything in the data warehouse? Yeah, so to be clear, you could, as I just described, write your own little script to get the data from the Apple Crash Report API and load it into your data warehouse. But this is a problem called extract and load or data movement, data integration, data ingestion.
正是这个 Singer 连接器库，我们 Meltano 拥抱并围绕它构建了一个平台，这样你就不用每次都去做编写自己的 Python 脚本的工作了。并且你可以利用更广泛的社区已经完成的工作。并且你能够自行管理这个
Those are sort of the terms you want to Google, which a lot of companies have tried to solve by building these connectors for different data warehouses, different SaaS APIs, and having you pay some kind of subscription fee to do that work. So one of the things that makes Meltano different is that we have embraced an open source library of connectors for data sources, which today counts more than 300 different sources and destinations that are supported. And this standard is called Singer, named after the sewing machine, actually.
并改进开源脚本，而不是完全依赖某种专有的 SaaS 提取器节点产品，这就是数据摄取步骤。接下来的步骤是获取那些通常与应用程序的数据库结构相匹配的原始数据（这意味着你知道的列、表、行、主键），并将其转化为更接近你为分析方面想要提出的问题类型的东西。如果你只有一个数据库或一个单一的数据源，通常原始模式就足够了。你可能想要删除一些 PII
And it is this Singer library of connectors that we with Meltano have embraced and built a platform around so that you don't have to do this work of writing your own Python script again each time. And you can leverage the work that the wider community has already done. And you are able to self-manage this
列（即个人身份信息列），或者例如对它们进行哈希处理，以便你仍然可以分辨出不同的人之间的区别，而实际上无法分辨出他们是谁，然后针对它运行查询。但特别是当你开始拥有来自多个来源的数据时，就像你刚才说的，当你想要找出来自墨西哥城的人是否更早卡住或诸如此类的情况，或者谷歌广告或 Facebook 广告上的某个营销活动是否能让用户更深入地进入用户流程，或者是否比其他一些营销活动更有可能让他们转化为付费客户，你就必须能够组合这些数据。
and improve the open source scripts instead of fully relying on some kind of proprietary sas extractor node offering so that's the data ingestion step the next step then is to take that raw data which usually matches the database schema structure of the application which means you know columns you know tables rows primary keys and turning it into something that gets closer to the types of questions you want to ask for the analytical side. So if you just have a single database or a single data source, usually the original schema is going to be good enough. You might want to drop some PII
而且这些数据库连接不是你每次向数据仓库提出问题时都想做的事情，因为连接成本高昂。因此，你希望在数据转换层进行一定程度的预聚合，在这里你将这些表组合成分析数据表，这些表已经准确地将你想要比较或组合的数据放在同一个表中。
columns or which have personally identifying information, or you want to hash them, for example, so that you can still tell the difference between different people without actually being able to tell who they were, and then run queries against it. But especially once you start having data from multiple sources, like you were saying earlier, when you want to find out whether someone from Mexico City gets stuck earlier or something, or whether some marketing campaign on Google Ads or Facebook Ads gets people further into the user flow or makes them more likely to convert into paying customers than some other campaign, you got to be able to combine this data.
因此，在回答关于各种 API 中的任何类型数据的挑战中，数据提取和加载，然后是数据转换，然后是编写实际的分析查询，可以说是这个过程的步骤。在所有这些步骤中，你基本上都在处理代码，无论是处理你的分析问题的 SQL queries，
And those database joints are not something you want to do every single time you ask the question of the data warehouse because joints are expensive. So you want to do some amount of pre-aggregation at the data transformation layer where you combine these tables into analytics data tables that have exactly the data already together in the same table that you're going to want to compare or combine.
还是定义转换的 Python 脚本或 SQL 查询，或者是提取器节点管道的配置（随着你想要的模式的变化，它可能会随时间改变）。这些都是我们可以认为是代码的不同版本、迭代或修订的东西。
So in the challenge of answering questions about any kind of data you have in various APIs, data extraction and loading, then data transformation, and then writing the actual analytics queries are sort of the steps of the process. And in all of these steps, you're essentially dealing with code, whether it is the SQL queries that handle your analytics questions
所以版本控制可以直接应用。是的，这讲得通。是的，我想在这里暂停一下，谈谈这有多么难以置信的重要。我当时正在听一个游戏开发播客，这些是，抱歉，抱歉，游戏设计播客，这些是纯粹的游戏设计师，他们中的许多人不写任何代码，也不懂编程或类似的东西，他们纯粹在设计端。当时有一个人在谈论，从测试中他们
or the Python scripts or the SQL queries that define the transformations or just the configuration of the extractor node pipeline, which might change over time as you change the schema you want. These are things that we can think of as different versions or iterations or revisions of the code.
发现，当英雄，你知道的，击中敌人时，他们最初的设定是这样的。所以有这样一个敌人，这个敌人是一个骑士，一个全身披甲的骑士。当你击中骑士的盾牌时，你知道的，骑士没有受到任何伤害。它只是把它挡住了。你发出了这个，你听到了这个清脆的小击打声。但是当你击中骑士时，骑士会像闪烁红色一样，你知道的，显示你绕过了盾牌。你穿过了盾牌。但他们发出了相同的击打声，因为这就像全是金属，就像盾牌是金属，盔甲是金属，而他们通过 A/B 测试发现，这令人难以置信地无法令人满意，就像人们想要的或是
So version control sort of directly applies. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I want to pause just for one quick moment here and talk about how unbelievably important this is. I was listening to a game development podcast and these were, sorry sorry game design podcasts and these are like pure game designers a lot of them don't write any code or know how to program or anything like that they're purely on the design side there was one person talking about how from testing they
诸如此类的东西，你知道的，像，当他们从“为这两者使用相同的声音”（这在物理上是准确的）切换到不同的声音时。也许是不同类型的铿锵声或咕哝声。我不知道。用户参与度不会上升。所以这是其中之一，就像没有人能预见到这一点，对吧？这只能在事后才能看到。他们基本上开始走上这条路，因为他们通过数据发现这个 Boss 比其余的要不令人满意得多，对吧？
found that when the hero you know sort of hit the enemy, they originally had it. So there was this, the enemy was this knight, this fully armored knight. And when you hit the shield of the knight, you know, the knight didn't take any damage. It just sort of blocked it. And you made this, you heard this little clink sound. But then when you hit the knight, the knight like flashed red, you know, showed that you bypassed the shield. You got through the shield. But they had the same clink sound because it's like all metal it's like shields metal armors metal and what they found through a b testing was that that was unbelievably unsatisfying like people wanted like or like ah
发现当英雄击中敌人时，他们原本的设计是这样的。当时敌人是一个骑士，一个身穿全套盔甲的骑士。当你击中骑士的盾牌时，你知道的，骑士没有受到任何伤害。它只是挡下了攻击。你会发出这种声音，听到一声清脆的金属撞击声。但当你击中骑士本体时，骑士会闪烁红光，表明你绕过了盾牌。你突破了盾牌。但它们的撞击声是一样的，因为它们都是金属——盾牌是金属，盔甲也是金属。通过A/B测试，他们发现这让人感到极其不满意，人们想要的是……比如“啊”之类的反应，
or something like that you know like and when they switched to from uh from using the same sound for both of those which is you know is physically accurate to a different sound. Maybe it was a different type of clank or a grunt. I don't know. The user engagement won't weigh up. And so it's one of these things, it's like nobody could foresee that, right? It's only something you can see post hoc. And they basically started down this path because they found this one boss to be much less satisfying than the rest from data, right?
诸如此类的声音。当他们把这两种情况采用的相同音效（物理上很准确）切换为不同的音效时——也许是另一种撞击声或是一声闷哼，我也不太清楚——用户的参与度直线上升。所以这就是其中之一，没有人能预见到这一点，对吧？这只有在事后才能看出来。他们基本上是通过数据发现某个Boss比其余的要乏味得多，才开始走上这条探索之路的，对吧？
So no matter what you're building, you're building it for other people. And those people have a collective consciousness that you cannot be fully aware of, right? It's impossible. Even Steve Jobs, as much as people talk about Steve Jobs, you know, is constantly relying on data and iteration and feedback loops. And so, and so, so you're going to have to learn all of these things we're talking about to build anything that's successful, especially nowadays, which where it's so incredibly competitive. There's so many great apps out there in the app store, The Unity Store is so full of games, right? So this is absolutely critical to understand.
所以无论你在构建什么，你都是在为其他人构建。而这些人拥有一个你无法完全了解的集体意识，对吧？这是不可能的。即使是史蒂夫·乔布斯，尽管人们经常谈论史蒂夫·乔布斯，你也知道，他也在不断地依赖数据、迭代和反馈循环。因此，因此，要想构建任何成功的东西，你都必须学习我们正在讨论的所有这些事情，尤其是现在这个竞争极其激烈的时代。应用商店里有那么多优秀的应用程序，Unity应用商店里有那么多游戏，对吧？所以理解这一点绝对至关重要。
And I think, Doan, you're doing an amazing job kind of walking us through this. So we have this ETL system in place. We've got everything in a data warehouse, and then we've transformed it to something that allows us to do the analysis we want efficiently. How do we go from that to a website with a pie chart on it? We used to throw out a new term ETL, which might be new to the audience. So that stands for extract transform load. And I'm calling this out because the sort of the more modern version of this is actually ELT, where the transformation happens after the load process. And this is relevant because, you know, for those who are interested in the history, if you do the extracts, you have a script that basically notes all of the data from the sources into memory.
我想Doan你把我们带入这个话题的工作做得非常棒。所以我们有了这个 ETL 系统。我们将所有东西都放进了数据仓库，然后将其转换为允许我们高效进行所需分析的形式。我们如何从这一点过渡到一个带有饼图的网站呢？我们之前抛出了一个新词 ETL，这可能对听众来说很新。它代表提取、转换、加载（extract transform load）。我提出这一点是因为，这种方法的更现代版本其实是 ELT，即转换过程发生在加载过程之后。这一点很有相关性，因为，你知道的，对于那些对历史感兴趣的人来说，如果你进行提取，你就会有一个脚本，它基本上将源中的所有数据记录到内存中。
You can do the transformation into memory before even writing into the database. But that has a lot of, you know, heavy compute and memory requirements. But it is sort of traditional model where you use Python code or all kinds of algorithms to change that schema before it ever lands in the database. But one of the things that these new analytics databases are just also really good at is those kinds of transformations efficiently. So if you can define your transformation, not in terms of a Python script, but in terms of a SQL query, where it targets the raw data, and then the select query you write outputs the new query
你可以在写入数据库之前在内存中进行转换。但这有许多（你知道的）繁重的计算和内存需求。但这算是传统模型，即在你将模式写入数据库之前，使用 Python 代码或各种算法来更改该模式。不过，这些新型分析数据库同样非常擅长高效地处理这类转换。因此，如果你能定义你的转换——不是用 Python 脚本，而是用针对原始数据的 SQL 查询，然后你编写的 select 查询会输出新查询
or the new schema rather. You can define your transformations in SQL in a way that's easily version controllable and an analyst can actually help with and do it all in the data warehouse so that you can change your transformation over time. And instead of having to redo the entire extract pipeline,
或者说新模式。你可以用 SQL 定义转换，这种方式易于版本控制，分析师实际上也可以提供帮助并在数据仓库中完成所有这些操作，这样你就可以随着时间推移更改你的转换。而不必重做整个提取管道，
you can just run it against the raw data again and again and iterate quicker that way. So we think of it as ELT, not ETL. But then, yes, we've now talked about a tool for EL, extractor loads. Something for transformation, which in our open source land is typically DBT. Like I mentioned, for the EL side, Stinger is this really great, amazing technology for extractor load connectors. DBT stands for data build tool, which is this way of transformations with SQL.
你只需针对原始数据一遍又一遍地运行它，从而更快地进行迭代。所以我们认为这是 ELT，而不是 ETL。但随后，是的，我们现在讨论了一个用于 EL（提取、加载）的工具。用于转换的东西，在我们的开源领域通常是 DBT。就像我提到的，在 EL 方面，Singer 是一个非常棒、了不起的用于提取加载连接器的技术。DBT 代表数据构建工具（data build tool），这是一种使用 SQL 进行转换的方法。
And then the last step that you'll definitely need is like you said, getting some kind of pie chart somewhere. Well, if you're going to do a pie chart somewhere, you can just write your, you know, Python code
然后你绝对需要的最后一步，就像你说的，就是在某处弄个饼图。好吧，如果你要在某处做个饼图，你只需编写你的（你知道的）Python 代码
or your Jupyter notebook and directly target the data warehouse. What's more typical for data organizations is that they have a BI tool of some sort, which might be Looker or Tableau or Power BI or Superset and Metabase.
或者你的 Jupyter 笔记本，并直接针对数据仓库。对于数据组织来说更典型的是，他们拥有某种 BI 工具，可能是 Looker、Tableau、Power BI、Superset 或 Metabase。
BI is business intelligence, by the way. Yeah, business intelligence, exactly. Those are the types of tools that allow you to define dashboards and reports and give you all kinds of choices and visualization methods. And you don't need to write code for it, so it's no pie chart involved. It's sort of point and click. Because in most cases, these data analysts are less technical than the programmers who are at the beginning of the data journey. Data engineers are quite technical. They know code.
顺便说一句，BI 是商业智能（business intelligence）。是的，商业智能，完全正确。这些类型的工具允许你定义仪表板和报告，并为你提供各种选择和可视化方法。你不需要为此编写代码，所以不涉及饼图。这有点像点按。因为在大多数情况下，这些数据分析师的技术水平不如数据之旅开端的程序员。数据工程师的技术能力相当强。他们懂代码。
They're pretty comfortable or getting comfortable with version control. Data analysts most of the time come from an Excel world where they are used to just looking at the data in a tabular form and then writing the queries to get the sort of the metrics and aggregates that we're looking for. And in the open source space, Superset and Metabase are two really great BI tools. Outside of that, like I mentioned earlier, Tableau, Looker, Mode, there's a whole long list of them that teams use. But yes, by then you are at the point where you have a dashboard and it shows you the number and you can see whether this month was better than last month or you can see whether campaign A
他们对版本控制相当熟悉，或者正在变得熟悉。数据分析师大部分时间来自 Excel 世界，他们习惯于只以表格形式查看数据，然后编写查询来获取我们正在寻找的指标和聚合。在开源领域，Superset 和 Metabase 是两个非常棒的 BI 工具。除此之外，就像我刚才提到的，Tableau、Looker、Mode，团队使用的工具有很长的一串。但是的，到那时你就到了这样一个阶段：你拥有一个仪表板，它向你显示数字，你可以看到这个月是否比上个月好，或者你可以看到 A 营销活动
did better than campaign B or like you were saying in the A-B testing scenario with the video game, you can see how much more time people spent on the game with the grunt versus the, you know, the clink sounds on the sword.
是否比 B 营销活动做得更好，或者就像你刚才在视频游戏的 A-B 测试场景中所说的那样，你可以看到人们在玩带有低沉怪声（grunt）的游戏与带有（你知道的）剑的清脆撞击声（clink）的游戏时多花了多少时间。
But all of these things, they are obviously really intertwined. Like if you want to ask a new type of question of your data, or you want to have new data involves, you got to go to the data engineer and ask them to write a new EL pipeline to do a new transformation. And then you can write a new query. But these currently live in siloed off little environments, the people that use these tools might not actually be talking all that much, it's more throw a request over the wall, and then two days later, hopefully you've solved it. And we think of this very much as one change set
但所有这些事情，它们显然是紧密交织在一起的。比如，如果你想对你的数据提出一种新的查询，或者你想引入新数据，你必须去找数据工程师，要求他们编写一个新的 EL 管道来做新的转换。然后你就可以编写一个新的查询。但这些目前生活在各自孤立的小环境中，使用这些工具的人实际上可能并没有进行太多的交流，它更像是把一个请求扔过墙，然后两天后，希望你已经解决了它。我们非常倾向于将其视为一个变更集
that happens to be spread across different tools, but it's something that you should be thinking of as one change to your data platform rather than separate changes to each tool involved. And we bring those changes together in one repository. We bring those applications, those different tools together in one repository. And we essentially bring the entire data team together in one place so that they can also collaborate more effectively and know what the other is doing
它恰好分布在不同的工具中，但你应该将其视为对数据平台的单一更改，而不是对所涉及的每个工具的单独更改。我们将这些更改集中在一个版本库（repository）中。我们将这些应用程序、这些不同的工具集中在一个版本库中。我们本质上将整个数据团队聚集在一个地方，以便他们也能更有效地合作，了解彼此在做什么，
and give feedback on each other's work and get to a place where a data analyst feels confident actually suggesting a change to the data pipeline through a pull request, knowing that they can make dumb mistakes, but they won't accidentally break production because it's going to have to go through that code review and CICD process anyway. So the sort of siloing we're seeing or the situation where a data team might not even allow a junior engineer to go into the system and make changes because the chance of accidentally breaking something that's just too high is, of course, limiting the effectiveness of these
并对彼此的工作提供反馈，达到这样一种状态：数据分析师有信心通过拉取请求（pull request）实际建议对数据管道进行更改，因为他们知道自己可能会犯愚蠢的错误，但他们不会意外破坏生产环境，因为无论如何它都必须经过代码审查和 CI/CD 流程。因此，我们看到的这种孤岛现象，或者数据团队甚至不允许初级工程师进入系统进行更改的情况——因为意外破坏某些东西的几率太高了——当然限制了这些
teams and their ability to quickly iterate and improve. And like you called out earlier, your data platform is a massive competitive advantage. If you know better how you can make your customers or your users paying customers or make them stick with you for longer or do exactly the new feature that they want, you're going to do better than your competitors. And right now, data tooling is not built in a way that actually allows data teams to get the most of it. And that's where Montana comes in.
团队的效率以及他们快速迭代和改进的能力。就像你刚才指出的那样，你的数据平台是一个巨大的竞争优势。如果你更清楚如何让你的客户或用户成为付费客户，或者让他们更长时间地留存，或者完全做出他们想要的新功能，你就会比你的竞争对手做得更好。而现在，数据工具的构建方式并没有真正让数据团队充分利用它。这就是 Meltano 登场的原因。
And like I said, it's open source. So everyone can just download it and give it a try today. And we are building commercial offering around it, but we want to make the barrier for people getting value really low. And that also means that we have a large community of users and contributors that, as I said earlier, you listening today can also become part of
就像我说的，它是开源的。所以每个人今天都可以下载并尝试一下。我们正在围绕它构建商业产品，但我们希望将人们获取价值的门槛降得非常低。这也意味着我们拥有庞大的用户和贡献者社区，正如我刚才所说，今天正在收听节目的你也可以成为其中一部分，
if you want to get job opportunities potentially through this field, or you want to be at the vanguard the forefront of this modern approach to data engineering cool yeah that makes sense so yeah one thing that's not totally clear is how you handle the fact that there's data in the loop so for we talked about soft parallels to software development and in software development you have version control, you have all of these things. It's not clear how data fits in. Like if I'm writing a software application, I have a bunch of.ini files
如果你想通过这个领域获得潜在的工作机会，或者你想成为现代数据工程方法的前沿先锋。酷，是的，这讲得通。所以，是的，有一点不是很清楚，那就是你如何处理循环中存在数据的事实？因此，我们谈到了与软件开发的软相似性，在软件开发中你有版本控制，你有所有这些东西。目前还不清楚数据是如何融入其中的。比如，如果我正在编写一个软件应用程序，我有一堆 .ini 文件
or.json files that are specific on my config and they just go straight into source control with everything else. Yeah, I can't imagine putting all the user data into Git or I don't think it's going to work. So yeah, how do you handle the fact that now there's data involved with this? Like, how do you do versioning here?
或者特定于我的配置的 .json 文件，它们和所有其他东西一起直接进入源代码管理。是的，我无法想象把所有用户数据都放进 Git，或者我觉得这行不通。所以，是的，你们如何处理现在有数据参与进来的事实？比如，你们在这里是如何做版本控制的？
That's a really good question. And DataOps is sort of orthogonal in that there is the part where we're applying these iteration strategies and tools to the actual code or technology that powers all the data flows, which is what we've been focused on so far, because that's where a ton of gain is to be had.
这是一个非常好的问题。DataOps 在某种程度上是正交的，其中有一部分是将这些迭代策略和工具应用于为所有数据流提供动力的实际代码或技术，这也是我们到目前为止一直关注的重点，因为这里有大量的收益。
We have not ourselves looked into versioning the data itself or data validation. Although data validation, adding some kind of testing pipeline that will tell you if the data is suddenly looking different than you expected it to, or if instead of a hundred records per day, you're only seeing 20. There's other tools that focus on that,
我们自己并没有研究对数据本身进行版本控制或数据验证。尽管数据验证——添加某种测试管道，当数据突然看起来与你预期不同，或者你每天看到的不是一百条记录而是只有 20 条时，它会告诉你——有其他工具专注于此，
and we support those on Meltano as components that can be brought into your Meltano project. And we can then help you version the testing criteria themselves. The data itself is not typically versioned, in large part because you don't always need the old versions, and it can be extremely expensive if you have a lot of that data. And part of the point of these data platforms
我们在 Meltano 上将这些作为组件支持，可以引入到你的 Meltano 项目中。然后我们可以帮助你对测试标准本身进行版本控制。数据本身通常不会进行版本控制，很大程度上是因为你并不总是需要旧版本，而且如果你有大量此类数据，成本可能会极其昂贵。这些数据平台的部分意义在于
is that you want them to be sort of reproducible, where your data pipeline defines the entire flow from the API to the desired format and graphs, which means that the data itself, as long as it's still in the SAS APIs, you can upgrade your platform and just rerun the pipeline again, and you'll pull out all the new data and be at the latest state. If you want to version your data, that's
在于你希望它们是某种可复现的，你的数据管道定义了从 API 到所需格式和图表的整个流程，这意味着只要数据仍然在 SaaS API 中，你就可以升级你的平台并重新运行管道，你将提取所有新数据并处于最新状态。如果你想对你的数据进行版本控制，那
not something we are focused on. There's other tools that have been working on that. But we think that that's the next step. Once people are comfortable with this concept of versioning and different feature branch pipelines, et cetera, versioning the data itself is the next step, which we will probably get to eventually. But what we will likely do is look for the most promising open source technology that is working on that problem and adopt those as supportive components on top of the Maldano platform. That makes sense. So if we do this ELT, where we get the data into the data warehouse, and then we apply transformations to it. How does that handle the changes on the software side? So I load today's data and I rename a field.
并不是我们关注的重点。有其他工具一直在致力于此。但我们认为这是下一步。一旦人们适应了版本控制和不同功能分支管道等概念，对数据本身进行版本控制就是下一步，我们最终可能会实现它。但我们可能会做的是，寻找正在解决该问题的最有前途的开源技术，并将其作为 Meltano 平台之上的支持组件采用。这讲得通。因此，如果我们做这个 ELT，即我们将数据导入数据仓库，然后对其应用转换。这如何处理软件端的变化？所以我加载今天的数据并重命名一个字段。
And so my field is called time, but I spelt it T-H-Y-M-E. And then I realized like three months in, oh, shoot, it should be T-I-M-E. And so I change it. And so now I have this data that has two different schemas, right? And so how do you handle the fact that the app developers are constantly making changes? What happens in that case is that you need to modify your data transformation SQL queries at the same time as the upstream changes, essentially. So your analytics queries are written to an analytics schema,
所以我的字段叫 time，但我把它拼成了 T-H-Y-M-E。然后大约过了三个月我意识到，哦，糟糕，应该是 T-I-M-E。于是我改了它。所以现在我有这些具有两种不同模式（schemas）的数据，对吧？那么，你们如何处理应用程序开发人员不断做出更改这一事实呢？在这种情况下发生的事情是，你需要同时修改你的数据转换 SQL 查询以及上游更改，本质上是这样的。你的分析查询是针对分析模式编写的，
which is derived from the raw schema that comes from the transactional database that your application developers are working on. So when the application developers change their schema, then the data pipelines would break because the source they're targeting doesn't match anymore. But you can update the data transformation SQL queries, still have the same output format, so that your analytics queries and your dashboards don't need to change,
它源自你的应用程序开发人员正在使用的事务性数据库中的原始模式。因此，当应用程序开发人员更改他们的模式时，数据管道就会损坏，因为他们定位的源不再匹配。但是你可以更新数据转换 SQL 查询，仍然具有相同的输出格式，这样你的分析查询和仪表板就不需要更改，
and just modify the way that that same output schema is derived from the input data. But this is also where a lot of data teams run into problems, because they are dependent on upstream data providers, which might be APIs, which are relatively slow moving. They have clear change logs. They have different versions in many cases. But you might also have application developers within your own company who are not really aware of what's happening downstream of that data.
只需修改从输入数据派生相同输出模式的方式。但这也是许多数据团队遇到问题的地方，因为他们依赖上游数据提供商，这些提供商可能是 API，其更新速度相对较慢。它们有清晰的变更日志。在许多情况下，它们有不同的版本。但你公司内部可能也有应用程序开发人员，他们并不真正知道该数据下游发生了什么。
So one of the things that Meltano allows is for the CICD pipeline of the main application code and the CICD pipeline of the data application code and the CICD pipeline of the data platform to also be connected so that the application developers can be informed when their change would break something so that the data team gets a chance to accommodate that change in the same pull request or in a related pull request to the upstream change so that they can be deployed at the same time. Instead of the data engineer finding out that suddenly their production dashboard is broken, and then having to scramble to fix it while their CFO is telling them like, hey, I've got this work meeting tomorrow,
因此，Meltano 允许的事情之一就是将主应用程序代码的 CI/CD 管道、数据应用程序代码的 CI/CD 管道以及数据平台的 CI/CD 管道也连接起来，以便在应用程序开发人员的更改会破坏某些东西时能够通知他们，从而让数据团队有机会在上游更改的同一拉取请求或相关拉取请求中适应该更改，以便它们可以同时部署。而不是数据工程师发现他们的生产仪表板突然损坏了，然后不得不争分夺秒地修复它，而他们的财务总监却在一旁对他们说，嘿，我明天有个工作会议，
like, why isn't this done yet? So being able to combine or to bring the data platform into the same development workflow where the complete downstream impact of any changes is validated before stuff goes live is part of the value you get from building your data platform like a software project and bringing in these CICD benefits. Got it. I see. That makes sense. So you have a pull request that fixes a column name in your application. That pull request kicks off some kind of continuous integration job, which is going to run your app, generate some data, then try to ingest that data and produce, let's say, a really sparse dashboard.
为什么还没搞定？因此，能够将数据平台组合或引入到同一个开发工作流中，在该工作流中，任何更改的完整下游影响在上线前都得到验证，这是将你的数据平台构建得像一个软件项目并引入这些 CI/CD 好处所带来的价值的一部分。明白了。我懂了。这讲得通。所以你有一个修复应用程序中列名的拉取请求。该拉取请求启动某种持续集成作业，它将运行你的应用，生成一些数据，然后尝试摄取该数据并生成，比方说，一个非常稀疏的仪表板。
And when it does that, it's going to fail because the part that's producing that dashboard is expecting a different column name. And so then now you realize, oh, this change actually requires a complimentary change on the data engineering side to say, you know, if the date is newer than this, then or if the version of the software is newer than this, then use this name for the column, otherwise that name. Now you get the dashboard working again. And maybe after a year or so, you can go and get rid of that if statement once you've purged all that old data or something.
当它这样做时，它将失败，因为生成该仪表板的部分期望不同的列名。于是现在你意识到，哦，这个更改实际上需要在数据工程端进行相应的更改，以说明，你知道的，如果日期比这更新，或者如果软件版本比这更新，那么为此列使用这个名字，否则使用那个名字。现在你让仪表板重新工作了。也许过了一年左右，一旦你清除所有旧数据或类似的东西，你就可以去摆脱那个 if 语句。
Yeah, that's exactly right. And the goal here, just like on the software development world, is for production to never be broken, or at least for if production is broken, having the ability to roll back quickly. And on the data side, the more this becomes the brain of the organization and the more people rely on this, the more important it is that they have the same confidence in those data dashboards never breaking as the organization has about their main, you know, web-based product or the app that they have live somewhere.
是的，完全正确。这里的目标，就像在软件开发世界中一样，是让生产环境永不损坏，或者至少在生产环境损坏时，有能力快速回滚。而在数据端，这越成为组织的大脑，越多的人依赖它，他们对这些数据仪表板永不损坏的信心，就与组织对其核心的、你知道的、在线网页产品或他们上线的应用程序的信心一样重要，这一点就越发重要。
Cool. So, okay. So if somebody is, let's say, a college student, I mean, you know, you can use your early self as an example. You know, someone is a college student, I mean, you can use your early self as an example. Someone is a college student, they're starting a small company, or they have a senior design project, and that involves sort of a closed loop with a lot of customers out there. What is the bare bones, or not bare bones, I say, what is the sort of cheapest way that a college student can get a pipeline like this and data ops off the ground? The answer is definitely Meltano. And specifically, you can run Meltano anywhere you like.
酷。所以，好吧。如果有人，比方说，是一个大学生，我的意思是，你知道的，你可以用早期的自己作为例子。（你知道的，你可以用早期的自己作为例子。）有人是一个大学生，他们正在创办一家小公司，或者他们有一个高级设计项目，这涉及到与外面大量客户的闭环。对于大学生来说，获得这样一个管道和 DataOps 并落地的最基础的，或者说不是最基础的，我应该说，最便宜的方式是什么？答案绝对是 Meltano。具体来说，你可以在你喜欢的地方运行 Meltano。
Like it's open source software. We are building some commercial functionality around it, but definitely if you're a color student or you're working on a small startup, you can download the code and get a pipeline running on your local machine in a matter of 30 minutes, all the way from having a dashboard up and running based on some data that was previously just hidden in some SaaS API.
就像它是开源软件一样。我们正在围绕它构建一些商业功能，但如果你是一名大学生或正在从事一个小型初创公司，你绝对可以下载代码并在短短 30 分钟内在你的本地机器上让一个管道运行起来，一直到基于一些以前只隐藏在某些 SaaS API 中的数据启动并运行一个仪表板。
And we have a number of demos and speed run examples of this on our website. Running it on your local machine, super easy and cheap. Then if you want to actually run it continuously somewhere, you can use even something like GitHub Actions or GitLab CI to run that pipeline in a recurring fashion. If you want to host the dashboard somewhere, you do need some way of spinning up a Docker container and exposing that in a web interface. But that's where Amazon and GCP and Azure have all of their own container scheduling functionality.
我们在我们的网站上有许多这方面的演示和快速运行示例。在你的本地机器上运行它，超级简单且便宜。然后，如果你真的想在某处持续运行它，你甚至可以使用诸如 GitHub Actions 或 GitLab CI 之类的方法以循环的方式运行该管道。如果你想在某处托管仪表板，你确实需要某种方式来启动一个 Docker 容器并在 Web 界面中将其暴露出来。但这就是亚马逊、GCP 和 Azure 拥有各自容器调度功能的地方。
And you can even just take a Linux box somewhere and use Docker Compose to spin up the web interface, which is also something I have on my own home lab, for example. Yeah, so what connectors would you recommend? So we talked about Singer. So if someone's making a video game, let's say, so they're writing code in Unity. I'm assuming there's like a Singer.
你甚至可以随便找一个 Linux 主机，使用 Docker Compose 来启动 Web 界面，这也是我自己的家庭实验室里有的东西，例如。是的，那么你推荐哪些连接器呢？所以我们讨论了 Singer。因此，如果有人在制作视频游戏，比方说，他们在用 Unity 编写代码。我假设有一个类似于 Singer 的东西……
Singer has a way of getting, you know, I guess, blobs of JSON from Unity into a data warehouse. I mean, I don't know well enough where Unity would store that data. If that data is on an API somewhere, you can write a connector or one might already exist. If you can get that data into S3 or into some kind of FTP folder, then you can use the existing connectors for those. But the expectation is that the data is currently somewhere where you can get it out of it, usually with an API or some kind of database query.
Singer 有一种方法可以将（你知道的）来自 Unity 的 JSON 数据块（blobs）获取到数据仓库中。我的意思是，我不是很清楚 Unity 会把这些数据存储在哪里。如果这些数据在某个 API 上，你可以编写一个连接器，或者可能已经存在一个。如果你能将这些数据放入 S3 或某种 FTP 文件夹中，那么你就可以使用现有的连接器来处理它们。但期望是，数据目前位于某个你可以将其取出的地方，通常使用 API 或某种数据库查询。
Okay, got it, got it, got it. So, okay, let me take a step back here. Okay, so someone needs to use like Amazon Kinesis or one of these things, you know, you have a million users out there who are all running something, website, app, game, et cetera. You need to get it in one place. And so that will be outside of Meltana.
好的，明白了，明白了，明白了。所以，好吧，让我退一步讲。好吧，有人需要使用诸类亚马逊 Kinesis 的东西，你知道的，外面有一百万用户都在运行某些东西，网站、应用程序、游戏等。你需要把它放在一个地方。所以那将是在 Meltana 之外。
There'll be something and there'll be Kinesis or there'll be some, you know, Kafka, some type of like endpoint where you could put this data in. It doesn't even need to be that low level. Like there's a lot of, you don't even need to pick
会有一些东西，会有 Kinesis，或者会有一些（你知道的）Kafka，某种你可以放入这些数据的端点。它甚至不需要那么底层。就像有很多，你甚至不需要挑选
a technology like that per se. There's a lot of products that have libraries for iOS and JavaScript and whatever else that allow you to track these user events. And those tools like mix panel or segment those all have apis that you can pull the information from into your data pipeline yeah okay
诸如此类的技术。有很多产品都有适用于 iOS、JavaScript 和其他任何允许你跟踪这些用户事件的库。这些工具，比如 Mixpanel 或 Segment，都有你可以将信息从其中提取到你的数据管道中的 API，是的，好吧
got it i got it okay so there's some like yeah let's say like user breadcrumb if you if you're a college student go out there punch in like you know user breadcrumb and then whatever you're doing like video game app whatever there's some service that you can use that's free that will allow you to kind of put that data there. And then Singer will connect to that and put it into a data warehouse. Correct. And for the data warehouse right now, the most popular solutions in sort of real life production use cases are some of these paid products like Snowflake, BigQuery, Redshift. But you can start simple with just a Postgres database, which, like I just said earlier,
明白了，我明白了，好吧，所以有一些——是的，比方说像用户面包屑（user breadcrumb），如果你是一个大学生，出去输入像（你知道的）“用户面包屑”，然后无论你在做什么，比如视频游戏、应用程序，都有某种你可以免费使用的服务，它允许你把数据放在那里。然后 Singer 将连接到该服务并将其放入数据仓库。正确。至于目前的数据仓库，在现实世界的生产用例中最流行的解决方案是其中一些付费产品，如 Snowflake、BigQuery、Redshift。但你可以从一个简单的 Postgres 数据库开始，就像我刚才说的，
is not necessarily going to handle massive analytical workloads. But for your college project, that's more than enough. And you can get a full data pipeline end-to-end with the dashboard and pulling stuff from various APIs up and running, like I mentioned, in a matter of 30 minutes to an hour. But what I would suggest, if I mentioned, in a matter of 30 minutes to an hour. But what I would suggest, if this is something that interests you and you want to play around with it, is to identify maybe not even a business source, but something fun in your life.
它不一定能处理海量分析工作负载。但对于你的大学项目来说，这已经绰绰有余了。你可以获得一个端到端的数据管道，带有仪表板，并从各种 API 拉取数据并运行，就像我提到的，在 30 分钟到一小时内。但我建议的是——如果我提到的，在 30 分钟到一小时内。但我建议的是，如果这是你感兴趣并且想把玩的东西，是去确定一个也许甚至不是业务来源的东西，而是你生活中的某种有趣的东西。
Like if you do a lot of cycling, you could use Strava or you can use whatever other fitness app you're using, or you could even start with tracking your personal finances and see if your bank has an API or a crypto platform, why not? But if you find a data source in your own life, some kind of tool you use that has an API, you can build a Singer connector for that using our Meltano SDK, and then build a pipeline with Meltano and Singer and BBT and some of these other projects I've mentioned to create a customized
比如如果你经常骑自行车，你可以使用 Strava，或者你可以使用你正在使用的任何其他健身应用程序，或者你甚至可以从跟踪你的个人财务开始，看看你的银行是否有 API 或加密货币平台，为什么不呢？但如果你在自己的生活中找到了一个数据源，某个你使用的带有 API 的工具，你可以使用我们的 Meltano SDK 为其构建一个 Singer 连接器，然后用 Meltano、Singer、BBT 以及我提到的其他一些项目构建一个管道，为你试图追踪的你生活中的任何指标创建一个定制的
dashboard for whatever metric in your life you're trying to track. But there's a lot of hobbyists using it for these sort of quantified life, quantified self use cases, which is honestly a far more fun demo than yet another business platform or business use case. Yeah, that makes sense. One caveat there, one word of caution, if you're going to use this to track the value of your NFTs, you really have to watch out for those underflow errors. An integer can only hold, what is it, negative 2 billion. So once you start losing more money than that, you're in trouble. What about on the dashboard side? You mentioned Metabase and Superset. Do you have a particular preference, especially if you're a beginner? Is there one that you'd recommend more than another?
仪表板。但有很多爱好把它用于这种“量化生活、量化自我”的用例，老实说，这比又一个商业平台或商业用例要有趣得多。是的，这讲得通。这里有一个告诫，一句警告，如果你要用它来追踪你的 NFT 的价值，你真的必须小心那些下溢（underflow）错误。一个整数只能容纳，是多少，负 20 亿。所以一旦你开始损失比这更多的钱，你就麻烦了。在仪表板方面呢？你提到了 Metabase 和 Superset。你是否有特别偏好的，特别是如果你是个初学者？有没有一个是你更推荐的？
Yeah. So Superset and Metabase, they're both open source business intelligence solutions. Superset, I think, is a little bit more mature when it comes to competing with some of these paid BI products. And there's a lot of different visualization methods. But the user interface is also a little bit more difficult. The learning curve is slightly higher. With Metabase, it's really easy to start exploring your data and seeing if you can pull some graphs out of it. And it definitely has enough visualization functionality for any sort of hobbyist or student use cases. But large businesses, we see using Superset more often. Smaller projects, Metabase is a really
是的。所以 Superset 和 Metabase，它们都是开源的商业智能解决方案。Superset，我认为在与其中一些付费 BI 产品竞争时稍微成熟一些。并且有很多不同的可视化方法。但用户界面也稍微困难一些。学习曲线略高。对于 Metabase，开始探索你的数据并看看是否能从中提取一些图表真的很容易。对于任何爱好或学生用例，它绝对拥有足够的可视化功能。但对于大型企业，我们看到人们更经常使用 Superset。对于较小的项目，Metabase 是一个非常
great start. Cool. That's awesome. And so Meltano is a platform that underpins a lot of these things. So you could start with Meltano and you start adding these connectors. As you do, they become kind of pull requests that grow into this amalgam that you end up with, where you can now run your app maybe yourself. And then you can look at the pie chart and see your own data and say okay this is working and now i can send this out to a bigger audience yeah exactly meltano is the foundation essentially of your of your data platform it is the project that lets you build this repository that then brings together all of these components that you can add one by one as you need
不错的开始。酷。这太棒了。所以 Meltano 是支撑许多这些事情的平台。所以你可以从 Meltano 开始，然后开始添加这些连接器。当你这样做时，它们变成了拉取请求，最终增长成你最终得到的这个融合体，在这里你现在可以自己运行你的应用。然后你可以查看饼图并查看你自己的数据，并说“好吧，这在工作，现在我可以把它发送给更大的受众了”。是的，完全正确，Meltano 基本上是你数据平台的基石，它是让你构建这个版本库的项目，该版本库随后将所有这些组件汇集在一起，你可以根据需要逐个添加
them from the connectors to the transformation tool like dbt and then to a visualization tool like superset and then what you end up with is one repository that holds every aspect of your end-to-end data story that can be deployed as a single docker container onto any sort of docker compatible platform including your local machine if you're using something like Docker Compose. And it's Meltano that standardizes the configuration of all these components, allows all of their assets and configuration to be version-controlled,
它们，从连接器到像 dbt 这样的转换工具，再到像 superset 这样的可视化工具。最后你会得到一个版本库，它保存了你的端到端数据故事的各个方面，可以作为单个 Docker 容器部署到任何与 Docker 兼容的平台上，包括你的本地机器，如果你使用的是像 Docker Compose 这样的工具。正是 Meltano 标准化了所有这些组件的配置，允许它们的所有资产和配置进行版本控制，
and helps with the deployment of the entire thing as well. Cool, that makes sense. So Meltano, the company, why don't you tell us a little bit about how that got started? I understand it was a spin-out of GitLab, but at what point was there sort of a decision made that, yes, this should be its own company? How does a company decide on spinning something out? And what was that story all about?
并且还有助于整个事情的部署。酷，这讲得通。那么 Meltano 这家公司，你为什么不给我们讲讲它是怎么开始的呢？我听说它是从 GitLab 分拆出来的，但在什么情况下做出了这样的决定，即是的，这应该成为它自己的公司？一家公司是如何决定分拆某项业务的？那个故事到底是怎样的？
Yeah, good question. So, like I said earlier, from the beginning, GitLab realized that there's a big opportunity here. This is a product that by itself could revolutionize a lot of the data industry and how people think about building their data platforms. But there was always this idea of either this is going to be an internal business unit, a second product of the big GitLab company, or it will spin out at some point to kind of go its own way. And by the time that Meltano was starting to show the kind of traction and growth and then community activity that warranted real growing out the team again and then spreading its wings, GitLab was a 2,000 people organization where every single person, except for myself,
是的，好问题。所以，就像我刚才说的，从一开始，GitLab 就意识到这里有一个巨大的机会。这是一个本身就可以彻底改变许多数据行业以及人们如何思考构建其数据平台的产品。但一直有这样一种想法：要么这将是一个内部业务部门，是大型 GitLab 公司的第二个产品，要么它将在某个时候分拆出去，走它自己的路。当 Meltano 开始显示出值得再次真正壮大团队并展翅高飞的吸引力、增长和社区活动时，GitLab 已经是一个拥有 2,000 人的组织，除了我之外的每一个人，
was working on this one product, one customer persona, one everything. And there were all kinds of tools in place that are really appropriate for a 2,000-person company, but not for a tiny little open-source project that was still before product-market fit, needed to start building out its team, needed to figure out a business model
都在致力于这一个产品、一个客户角色、一个一切。并且有各种各样的工具，这些工具对于一个 2,000 人的公司来说非常合适，但对于一个仍然在寻找产品市场契合点之前、需要开始组建团队、需要围绕这项开源技术弄清楚商业模式的小型开源项目来说并不合适。
around this open-source technology. So we realized pretty quickly that a lot of the process and administrative overhead in GitLab that was appropriate for a massive, you know, about to IPO organization was holding us back, slowing us down. And from GitLab's perspective,
所以我们很快意识到，GitLab 中许多适合一个庞大的、即将进行 IPO 的组织的流程和管理开销正在阻碍我们，让我们慢下来。从 GitLab 的角度来看，
the estimation was made that the value of Meltano as a spun out company in which it maintained the stake would be larger in terms of expected value over time than keeping it inside and sort of limiting its ability to spread its wings and grow. So this was really, yeah, a decision between myself and the GitLab CEO, Sid, who I referred to earlier. And considering that we had seen some of the difficulty around hiring people and the types
据估计，Meltano 作为一家分拆出来的公司（GitLab 在其中保持股份）在长期内的预期价值，将大于将其留在内部并某种程度上限制其展翅高飞和生长的能力。所以这确实是，是的，我和 GitLab 首席执行官 Sid（我之前提到过）之间做出的决定。考虑到我们在招聘人员方面看到了一些困难，以及早期初创公司与 GitLab 这样的后期公司相比典型的薪酬水平，这让我们觉得这是唯一的途径。正是在那时，我们开始寻找外部资金来凑齐种子轮，我们在去年 6 月完成了这一轮融资。所以我们现在已经进入独立征程的一年零两个月左右了。我们现在已经发展到 17 人了。
of compensation that is typical for an early startup versus a later stage company like GitLab made us think like this is the only route. And that's when we started looking for outside funding to get a seed round together, which we completed in June last year. So we're now a year and two months or so into our independent journey. And we've grown to 17 people right now.
正如我前面提到的，我们在今年早些时候再次筹集了资金，就在市场低迷之前，所以时机真的很好。我一直在想这件事。现在我们处于这样一个位置，我们的资金跑道（runway）一直延伸到 2024 年，所以我们有充足的时间
Like I mentioned earlier, we raised funding again earlier this year, just before the sort the market downturn so that was really good timing. I was wondering about that. And now we're in a position where our runway extends into 2024 so we've got a good amount of time to
来确切弄清楚我们如何将相当一部分开源用户群转化为付费客户，因为我们热爱开源，以及这是由人民创造、为人民服务的这一事实。工程师可以提供帮助。使用它的门槛超级低。因此，今天我们的许多受众将能够直接尝试这个。
work out exactly how we can convert a good amount of our open source user base into paying customers as well because we love the open source and the fact that this is by the people, for the people. Engineers can help it out. The barrier to using it is super low. So a lot of our audience today will just be able to give this a try.
但为了实现这种增长并尽可能多地接触到更多人，我们当然需要一些资金来继续构建这个。因此，商业开源挑战是我们必须在接下来的几个月中专注于解决的问题。我们将为那些不想自己管理部署的人推出 Meltano 的托管版本。他们不想学习 Terraform 或 Kubernetes
But in order for that growth and reaching as many people as possible, we, of course, need some money to keep building this too. So the commercial open source challenge is one that we have to focus on in the coming months. And we are going to be launching a managed version of Meltano for those people that don't want to self-manage their deployments. They don't want to learn Terraform or Kubernetes
或 Docker。他们不想处理如何拥有生产环境和暂存环境（staging environment）的问题？如何进行功能分支部署？这些都是我们可以通过自动化消除并收费的东西，这将是我们从仅仅一个商业开源项目迈向商业开源业务的第一次尝试。
or Docker. They don't want to have to deal with how do you have a production environment and a staging environment? How do you have feature branch deployments? That's all stuff that we can automate away and charge for, which will be our sort of first foray into being a commercial open source business more than just a commercial open source project.
酷，这讲得通。是的，我觉得责任是一个领域，如果你是一个开源项目并且能够减少责任，那是公司愿意付费的东西，同时（你知道的）黑客和个人开发者并没有那么感兴趣，所以你并不是真的从他们那里拿走很多东西，你仍然在为想要这些东西的人提供很多东西。是的，完全正确，小团队、组织、个人需要的东西与每个企业都会有的那种需求之间存在很大差异。
Cool. That makes sense. Yeah, I feel like liability is an area where if you're an open source project and you can reduce liability, that's something that companies will pay for and simultaneously you know hackers and and individual developers aren't as interested in so you're not really taking a lot away from them and you're still providing a lot to the people who want that yeah exactly there's a big difference between what small teams organizations individuals need and the sort of requirements that every enterprise will have.
任何规模超过 100 人的公司都需要与开源不同的东西。如果你真的想永远走开源和自管路线，你可以自己重新实现其中一些东西。当然，如果我们能为你处理好这一切，我们可以让事情变得比你不得不雇佣自己的工程师来围绕 Meltano 构建所有这些基础设施要容易得多。是的，绝对的。
Any kind of company larger than 100 people or so will need different stuff than the open source. And you could reimplement some of that stuff yourself if you really want to go with the open source and the self-managed approach forever. But of course, there's a lot of things we can make significantly easier than you having to hire your own engineer to build all this infrastructure around Meltano if we can handle it for you. Yeah, definitely.
酷。所以 Meltano 正在招聘吗？如果是这样，他们是在招聘全职、实习生、两者皆有、还是两者都不是？那里的现状是什么？好问题。这不是全面的招聘冻结，但考虑到更广泛的气候，我们稍微放慢了招聘计划。
Cool. So is Meltano hiring? If so, are they hiring like full-time, intern, both, neither? What's the status there? Good question. It's not a full hiring freeze, but we have slowed down our hiring plan a little bit considering the broader climate.
我们在 meltana.com/jobs 页面上有两个角色。其中一个是 SRE（站点可靠性工程师），即平台架构 SRE，它将帮助我们把这个托管平台构建成一个超级可靠的东西，我们可以围绕它构建业务。我们还在寻找 UI 和 UX 设计师，因为到目前为止，我们一直采用“开发者优先”的方法，一切都在 CLI（命令行界面）和 YAML 文件中，随着我们围绕 Notano 构建这种基于 Web 的界面，我们希望在用户界面方面投入更多。这是全职的。全部都是远程的。所以如果这听起来像你，那么一个
We do have two roles on the meltana.com slash jobs page. One of them is a SRE, platform architectural SRE, standing for Site Reliability Engineer, that will help us build out this managed platform into something super reliable that we can build the business around. And we are also looking for a UI and UX designer because so far we've had a very developer first approach where everything is in the CLI command line interface and YAML files, and we want to invest more on the user interface side of things as we built out this web based sort of interface around Notano. And this is full time. It's all remote. So if this sounds like you, then a
展示你技能的好方法是通过开源项目。但如果你已经符合我们正在寻找的角色的某些要求，那么我们也希望进行交流。但总的来说，我建议你加入我们的 Slack 社区，目前有超过 2,600 人，你可以通过 matano.com/slack 找到它，在那里你可以了解 Meltano，向该领域的其他专家提问，并获得想法。你可能想亲自贡献力量，使 Meltano 变得更好，并开始本质上构建那个真实世界代码的投资组合，以便在实际公司中为他们的数据管道提供动力，这可能会为你赢得在 Meltano 或 Meltano 的任何用户（正如我所说，有数千个）那里工作的机会。
great way to sort of show off your skills is through the Open Source project. But if you already meet some of those requirements of the roles we're looking for, then we'd also love to talk. But generally, I would recommend that you join our Slack community, which has more than 2,600 people right now, which you can find through matano.com slash slack, which is where you can learn about Meltano, ask questions from other experts in the space, and also get ideas. You might want to contribute yourself to make Meltano even better and start essentially building that portfolio of real life code to use that actual companies to power their data pipelines, which might get you a job at Meltano or any of Meltano's users, of which, like I said, there are thousands.
非常，非常酷。如果人们感兴趣，还有其他地方可以去吗？我的意思是，我们肯定会发布 Meltano 网站和 Slack。GitHub 仓库是不容错过的。GitHub.com/Meltano/Meltano。你会在那里找到所有的代码。
Very, very cool. Any other places that people should go to if they're interested? I mean, we'll definitely post the Meltano website and the Slack. The GitHub repo shouldn't be missed. GitHub.com slash Meltano slash Meltano. We'll find you all the codes.
非常、非常酷。如果人们感兴趣，还有哪些地方可以去了解？我的意思是，我们一定会发布Meltano的网站和Slack。GitHub仓库也不容错过，即github.com/Meltano/Meltano。你们可以在那里找到所有的代码。
And also, if you're curious about all of the data sources that Meltano supports, you can find these on the Hub, which is at hub.meltano.com, which has more than 300 different SaaS APIs and databases that Meltano can load data from or put data into. But that's a good start if you want to figure out your first data pipeline and whether you have some data in one of those SaaS applications that you want to build some dashboards around. Cool. And if people want to communicate about Meltano, I guess the Slack you mentioned seems like a clear place.
还有，如果你对Meltano支持的所有数据源感兴趣，可以在Hub上找到它们，网址是hub.meltano.com。这里有300多种不同的SaaS API和数据库，Meltano可以从中加载数据或将数据写入其中。如果你想找出你的第一个数据管道，或者想知道某个SaaS应用程序中是否有你想用来构建仪表盘的数据，这是一个很好的开始。太棒了。如果大家想就Meltano进行交流，我想你刚才提到的Slack似乎是一个显而易见的地方。
Is there a presence on Twitter or any other social media? Is Slack really the place that people should be on? If you want to talk with people about Meltano, then Slack is the place to be. Of course, we have Twitter as well, twitter.com.data, where you can learn about what we're up to and the new releases we have and just chat about Meltano to your current community.
Twitter或其他社交媒体上也有账号吗？Slack真的是大家应该去的地方吗？如果你想和大家讨论Meltano，那Slack确实是首选之地。当然，我们也有Twitter，网址是twitter.com.data，你可以在那里了解我们在做什么、有哪些新版本，并与现有的社区聊聊Meltano。
But definitely, if you want to speak to the experts, then Slack is the way to go. Cool. All right, Patrick, you don't need to get a Twitter account. You're off the hook. You just need to get a Slack account. Actually, Slack isn't an account thing, right? It's an account per workspace.
但毫无疑问，如果你想和专家交流，去Slack准没错。太好了。好的，帕特里克，你不需要去注册Twitter账号了。你解放了。你只需要一个Slack账号。实际上，Slack并不是那种传统的账号，对吧？它是按工作区划分账号的。
Per workspace. Yeah, exactly. So if you go to montana.com slash Slack, it will take you through the signup flow where you create a Montana-specific account to interact with all of us. Cool. Great.
按工作区划分。对，没错。所以如果你访问meltano.com/slack，它会引导你完成注册流程，让你创建一个专门用于Meltano的账号，以便与我们所有人互动。太好了。非常棒。
Yeah, folks out there, definitely do that. Definitely check out the repository. This is a no-brainer, something you can set up yourself easily we talked about earlier uh eks and uh how amazon is a incredibly generous free tier for college students so you could easily run meltano on a on like a t1 a kubernetes cluster of t1 micros or something totally doable um and uh yeah if you do use meltono for anything definitely shoot us an email and we will uh pass it along and so or we'll even post it on twitter and you
是的，各位听众，一定要去试试。一定要去看看代码仓库。这绝对是不需要动脑筋的事，你可以轻松自己搭建，就像我们之前讨论过的EKS，以及亚马逊如何为大学生提供极其慷慨的免费套餐，所以你可以很容易地在类似t1微型实例的Kubernetes集群上运行Meltano，完全可行。而且，如果你确实用Meltano做了什么，一定要给我们发邮件，我们会转发它，甚至会把它发到Twitter上，
know kind of highlight what you've been up to it'd be uh really great it's always great to see people uh using the technology that uh we talked about in the show yeah we'd love to see that. And like I said, I would not be where I was today if it wasn't for all of this open source technology that was available from a very young age and being able to become really great and hireable in a field just through your own perusing of the internet
你知道的，突出展示你一直在做的事情，这真的非常棒。看到大家使用我们在节目中讨论的技术，总是让人觉得很棒。是的，我们很乐意看到这一点。就像我说的，如果没有从很小的时候就能接触到的所有开源技术，以及通过自己浏览互联网就在一个领域变得非常优秀并具备就业能力，我就不会有今天的成就。
and open source projects is an amazing way into the tech industry. So reading open source code, contributing it and making the most of all the free content online is the best possible start to a tech career as far as I'm concerned. Yeah, that is really special.
通过阅读开源代码、贡献代码以及充分利用网上的所有免费内容，这是进入科技行业绝佳的途径。就我而言，阅读开源代码、贡献代码并充分利用网上的免费内容是开启科技职业生涯最好的起步方式。是的，这真的很特别。
Any last words for the audience out there? Any last bits of advice? Let's say somebody has went to college not for CS, so they went to college for economics or something like that how do you how would you recommend that person get into the field yeah so for me it was always just a matter of picking a a problem in my life some kind of itch i wanted to scratch something that i knew could be done with code but didn't exist yet and just not giving up until it was done and learning
对广大听众还有什么最后的寄语吗？有什么最后的建议？比方说，某人上大学读的不是计算机科学，而是经济学或类似专业，你觉得你会建议这样的人如何进入这个领域？对，所以对A我来说，这总是很简单的一件事，那就是在生活中挑选一个问题，找一个我想解决的痛点，某个我知道可以通过代码解决但当时还不存在的东西，然后坚持不懈直到完成它，并在此过程中学习
all the technologies along the way yeah but that has definitely become more complicated because when i started all you needed to build a website was html css and php and now you've got to learn 20 different javascript frameworks just to get you know hello world to show up so i would these days strongly recommend following some kind of course but there's a lot of amazing free content as well just so you start off feeling a little more confident than every website you find mentioning five terms you've never heard of before and just being discouraged that way pretty quickly but in terms of just writing really great code learning from the best is one of the great things about open source and and you can become
所有相关的技术。是的，但现在这肯定变得更复杂了，因为我刚开始的时候，构建一个网站只需要HTML、CSS和PHP，而现在你必须学习20种不同的JavaScript框架，仅仅为了让“Hello World”显示出来。所以我现在强烈建议报个某种课程，不过网上也有很多优秀的免费内容，这样你刚开始时就不会觉得每个网站都有五个你从未听过的术语，从而很快感到沮丧。不过，就编写优秀的代码而言，向最好的人学习是开源的巨大优势之一，你可以通过
a really great engineer just by reading code other people have written and seeing how it's done. Yeah, that makes a ton of sense. So yeah, I think we can put a bookmark in that. Thank you, Dawit, for coming on the show. We really appreciate it. Really interesting episode. I think it's a new topic. It's on the vanguard. It's something that people are going to be, it's going to be sort of a household name in a few years. So we were able to catch this really early, which is really special. And thanks, everybody, for supporting us out there on Patreon and through Audible. Thanks for subscribing to the show. The subscriber count is growing a ton, which is amazing. I actually am guilty of not doing very good data ops.
阅读别人写的代码并了解它是如何实现的，从而成为一名非常优秀的工程师。是的，这非常合理。所以，我想我们可以把这作为一个标记。谢谢达威特来参加我们的节目。我们非常感激。非常有趣的一集。我认为这是一个新话题，处于前沿领域。几年后，它将成为一个家喻户晓的名字。所以我们能够这么早就捕捉到这个话题，这非常特殊。谢谢大家在Patreon和Audible上对我们的支持。谢谢大家订阅本节目。订阅人数正在暴涨，这太惊人了。其实我自己在数据运营方面做得并不好，
So I honestly don't know why the subscriber count is growing. That's on me. But I should definitely get an El Tano instance up and running so I can figure this out. But regardless, we have a lot of folks, new folks to the show and welcome. I really appreciate all of you kind of coming in, listening, sending us emails, offering your support. And we will catch everyone in two weeks. Music by Eric Barneller.
所以我老实说不知道为什么订阅人数在增长。这怪我。但我绝对应该搭建并运行一个Meltano实例来弄清楚这一点。不过无论如何，有很多新朋友来到这个节目，欢迎你们。非常感谢大家加入、收听、给我们发邮件并提供支持。我们两周后见。音乐由埃里克·巴内勒提供。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Music by Eric Barndeller. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown采用知识共享署名协议发布。音乐由埃里克·巴恩德勒提供。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。